[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
heute ist die stunde der wahrheit heute
ist der tag der entscheidung es geht um
die allgemeine impfpflicht lange
angekündigt lange beraten lange
vorbereitet jetzt ist es soweit aber das
ganze ist äußerst kompliziert es dürfte
einen tag der taktik werden der
winkelzüge so hat es schon vorwürfe
gegeben und es dürfte äußerst spannend
werden denn das parlament will heute
abschließend über die einführung einer
corona impfpflicht entscheiden die
bundesregierung hat keinen eigenen
gesetzentwurf vorgelegt das sollte ja
parteiübergreifende vorschläge
erarbeitet werden eingebracht werden
dann sollte abgestimmt werden völlig
ohne fraktionszwang eine reine
gewissensentscheidung
so das ganze in der theorie in den
vergangenen monaten jetzt sieht es
allerdings konkret so aus vier
vorschläge stehen im raum liegen auf dem
tisch zwei davon der eine von
fdp-politiker kubicki der andere von der
afg lehnen eine allgemeine impfpflicht
eigentlich ab der vorschlag der union
forscher drei sieht eine dritte sieht
eine schrittweise lösung vor den aufbau
eines images das aber nicht direkt eine
allgemeine impfpflicht und der vierte
vorschlag der wohl am weitesten geht
kommt von einer gruppe von abgeordneten
aus der ampel koalition ein kompromiss
in letzter sekunde eine allgemeine
impfpflicht ab 60 für jüngere eine
verpflichtende impfberatung diesen
vorschlag unterstützen heute auch der
kanzler und
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach wir
wollen das ganze die abstimmung
natürlich verfolgen müssen aber dazu
sagen dass trickreiche das spannende
winkelzüge eben das ist sind gar nicht
auf die vier vorschläge bezogen sondern
auf die abstimmungs reihenfolge das
heißt heute gab es schon viele
diskussionen und wird heftig gestritten
in welcher reihenfolge abgestimmt werden
soll über diese vier vorschläge und
warum das ganze so entscheidend ist da
wollen wir reden mit unserer hauptstadt
korrespondent in andrea maurer die die
ganze abstimmung alles für uns im
parlament verfolgt andrea wenn du jetzt
zugeschaltet will hoffen wir sehen was
nicht steht die leitung in den bundestag
sie hört uns zumindest schon das höre
ich zumindest ich höre auch das klingeln
im parlament also die abgeordneten
versammeln sich und andrea ich würde
nicht zu sehen andrea würde ich gerne
fragen warum ist die reihenfolge der
abstimmung so entscheiden ist es nicht
eigentlich völlig egal wann über welchen
vorschlag abgestimmt jetzt sehen wir
dich andrea
und wenn du uns noch hören kannst und
die antwort parat was das trickreiche
ist warum die abstimmungs reihenfolge
also diese geschäftsordnung heute so
spannend ist warum erst mal vielleicht
minuten lang darüber abgestimmt wird wie
man diese geschäftsordnung macht das
muss uns erklären
also genau es wird jetzt hier erstmal
mit einer inhaltlichen debatte beginnen
aber dann wird eben das passieren was du
gerade beschrieben hast kassen also es
gibt eine geschäftsordnungsdebatte zur
eine abstimmung dann über die
reihenfolge der abstimmung und das ist
insofern trickreich als es eben ein
vorschlag der ampel koalition ist den
eigenen oder dem gesetzentwurf den die
meisten abgeordneten und auch der
kanzler und der gesundheitsminister
favorisieren eben am ende abstimmen zu
lassen sie erhoffen sich dadurch wohl
dass diese abstimmung am ende eine art
auffangbecken für stimmen werden könnte
das also auch vielleicht unions
abgeordnete die eine impfpflicht gerne
wollen und merken der unionsantrag ist
nicht durchgekommen sich dann entweder
beim gesetzentwurf enthalten oder selbst
auch zustimmen und da ist die union eben
konsequent dagegen die sagen es ist eine
parlamentarische gepflogenheit dass der
antrag der am weitesten geht zuerst
abgestimmt wird und deswegen eben diese
geschäftsordnungsdebatte insofern auch
interessant dass nicht klar ist ob die
ampel schon bei dieser abstimmung dann
eine mehrheit haben wird und das ist der
knackpunkt hier heute der sich durch den
ganzen tag das sieht es wurde versäumt
mehrheiten zu organisieren es hat jetzt
gestern und auch heute morgen noch viele
anrufe gegeben von hochrangigen ampel
politikern und politikerinnen bei der
opposition
ist sozusagen der versuch in letzter
minute
mehrheiten zu bekommen für zum einen
eben den vorschlag der reihenfolge und
dann natürlich zum anderen auch für
diesen gesetzentwurf der als kompromiss
jetzt im raum steht das ist also heute
tatsächlich spannend und es ist wirklich
in beiden fällen offen ob die ampel
koalition eine mehrheit bekommt und das
zeigt eben auch dass diese vier monate
debatte inzwischen so lange geführt
wurden und so zerfasert sind dass hier
viel parteitaktik heute eine rolle
spielen wird und das ist natürlich bei
einer entscheidung die er zur
gewissensentscheidung ausgerufen war
bedauerlich kann man eigentlich sagen
also die dinge haben sich in den letzten
wochen und monaten ein bisschen
verändert insofern hast du jetzt alle
mal skizziert warum das ganze heute
morgen spannend ist schon vor der
eigentlichen abstimmung die
parlamentsvorsitzende präsidentin bass
spricht und redet jetzt also schon mal
über reihenfolge über anträge wollen wir
rein hören denn das ganze dürfte
spannend sein und wir sehen auch die
vielen wichtigen player schon mal
zwischen geschnitten die auf den sitzen
inzwischen abc wird in verbindung mit
tagesordnungspunkt 25 aufgerufen ich
mache schließlich darauf aufmerksam dass
der gesetzentwurf auf drucksache 20
schrägstrich 737 nachträglich dem
ausschuss für inneres und heimat sowie
dem ausschuss für digitales überwiesen
werden soll auch hier sehe ich keinen
widerspruch dann ist das so beschlossen
ich rufe jetzt auf den
tagesordnungspunkt 6 beratung mehrerer
vorlagen zur einführung bzw zur nicht
einführung einer impfpflicht ich möchte
sie schon jetzt über das weitere
verfahren informieren nach der
aussprache werden wir zunächst die
reihenfolge der abstimmung festlegen da
hierüber kein einvernehmen erzielt
werden konnte hierzu ist dann auch das
wort zur geschäftsordnung gewünscht nach
der festlegung der reihenfolge beginnen
dann die namentlichen abstimmung über
die 1 sondern vorlagen das gesamte
abstimmungsverfahren kann
voraussichtlich bis zu zweieinhalb
stunden dauern
für die aussprache selbst wurde eine
dauer von 68 minuten beschlossen
ich weise auf die vereinbarungen hin
dass die reden der kolleginnen und
kollegen deren rede wunsch nicht
berücksichtigt werden kann diese reden
auch zu protokoll geben können und
hiermit würde ich jetzt die aussprache
beginnen und als erstes hat das wort die
kollegin dagmar schmidt für die gruppe
behrens janitschek und andere
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen allein gestern
wurden über 200.000 neuinfektionen
gemeldet knapp zweieinhalb tausend
menschen kam wegen und mit kidd ins
krankenhaus
340 menschen sind daran gestorben
das ist immer noch sehr und viel zu viel
aber es scheint trotz alledem aufwärts
zu gehen darum geht es heute aber nicht
es geht nicht um das was ist sondern um
das was mit sehr hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit im nächsten herbst
und winter sein wird und wofür wir heute
vorsorge treffen wollen
vorsorge dafür dass wir wieder steigende
infektionszahlen haben und dafür dass
die alten wieder kommen oder es neue
virusvarianten geben kann wir werden im
herbst wieder vor der gleichen
herausforderung die letzten herbst
stehen das virus wird nicht einfach
verschwinden und wir wollen vorsorge
betreiben das gesundheitssystem die
kritische infrastruktur vor allem aber
die gesundheit der menschen zu schützen
und entweder wir haben dann die
impflücken weitestgehend mit unserer
beratungs und impfpflicht geschlossen
dann werden wir eine grundimmunisierung
in der bevölkerung die einen
weitestgehend normalen umgang mit dem
virus zulässt haben und dafür sind wir
oder die imf lücke wird nicht
geschlossen und wir haben weiterhin
viele millionen menschen die keine
vollständige grundimmunisierung mit drei
virus kontakten haben und müssen dann
wieder maßnahmen ergreifen masken
abstand kontakt beschränkungen bis hin
zur schließung je nach schwere des virus
auch dafür auch dafür liebe diese
freiheitseinschränkung in kauf zu nehmen
kann man sich entscheiden oder wir
lassen es laufen mit allen konsequenzen
kranke tote überlastung des
gesundheitssystems der kritischen
infrastruktur und was wird longo wird
noch in gänze auf uns zukommt das wissen
wir noch gar nicht auch dafür kann man
sich entscheiden ich rate dann nur
besser nicht krank zu werden und keinen
unfall zu haben
und darauf will ich hinaus
man kann sich nicht gegen etwas
entscheiden ohne sich für etwas anderes
zu entscheiden wann trägt hier also
immer für das eine oder andere die
verantwortung und wenn man an der einen
oder anderen stelle liebe union sei es
eine beratungspflicht sei es eine
altersgrenze seien es datengrundlagen
seien es entscheidungsmechanismen an ins
register wenn man andere vorstellungen
oder ideen hat dann gibt es in einer
demokratie das bewährte verfahren der
verhandlung und des kompromisses und
diesen kompromiss haben wir mit ente
ullmann und seiner gruppe gefunden und
der sieht wie folgt aus erster gegeben
der beratung der aufklärung und direkten
ansprache eine chance und führen eine
beratungs nachweispflicht für alle ab 18
1 das kann ab sofort geschehen und wir
werden dafür werben um die
entsprechenden möglichkeiten auch
schaffen zweitens wir sorgen für den
herbst vor mit einer impfpflicht für die
über 60 jährigen damit schützen wir das
gesundheitssystem
und
schließen die impflücken vor allem war
der besonders wohlhabenden gruppe und
drittens sorgen wir perspektivisch für
eine große ruhe grund immunität alle
erwachsenen als voraussetzung für ein
normales gesellschaftliches leben
entweder dadurch dass die beratung und
aufklärung wirkt mit dem schwerpunkt
zunächst auf den über 60 jährigen und
einem bericht dazu ende mai wenn das
nicht wirkt dann bleibt es bei der
impfpflicht mit kontrollen ab und
nachweis erbringen bis herbst und dann
im herbst vor schnitt geschaffen werden
zwischenfrage aus der
situation der afg nein nein und dann im
herbst mit einer entscheidung für die 18
bis 59 jährigen auf grundlage eines
berichts über impflücken virus mutation
erwartbares infektionsgeschehen und so
weiter so dass es dann in einer
schwierigen situation eine impfpflicht
auch für die über 18-jährigen mit
einfachen beschluss geben kann und wir
über eine breite immunisierung wenn dann
auch etwas später aus der dann
schwierigen pandemischen lage
herauskommen werden noch ein
grundsätzlicher satz zum abschluss
putins krieg gegen die ukraine wird
weitere folgen haben die menschen in
unserem land unsere wirtschaft der
erhalt von arbeitsplätzen unser
sozialstaat werden vor große
herausforderungen gestellt wir haben
heute die chance im herbst nicht auch
noch mit den maßnahmen zur pandemie
bekämpfung zurecht kommen zu müssen
darum bitte ich um ihre zustimmung
[Applaus]
bevor ich den nächsten redner aufrufe
gibt es den wunsch nach einer
kurzintervention von den kollegen
ermordet
vielen dank frau präsidentin frau
kollegin ich bin 63 jahre alt ich bin
zweimal geimpft worden und ich hatte vor
zwei wochen eine corona erkrankung zwei
tage fieber das war es die behauptung
diese impfung würde in irgendeiner weise
also vor der erkrankung schützen ist
damit nachweislich falsch
bedauerlicherweise habe ich auch mehrere
mitglieder meiner familie mit dem virus
angesteckt die behauptung die impfung
würde also in irgendeiner weise vor der
ansteckung anderer menschen schützen ist
damit ebenfalls nachweislich falsch das
einzige was klar und beweisbar ist dass
eine impfung wenn sie dann durchgeführt
wird im allerbesten fall für drei monate
eine schutzwirkung entfaltet wenn es
überhaupt eine schutzwirkung gibt und
dann ist es damit vorbei und das macht
das ganze in höchstem maße absurd denn
was heißt das wenn diese
zwangsimpfung von ihnen durchgesetzt
wird das heißt dass ich mich selbst wenn
ich mich dann noch einmal impfen lassen
würde zum dritten mal es eine vierte
eine fünfte eine sechste impfung
benötigen würde und niemand auf der welt
nicht der gesundheitsminister nicht der
kanzler und auch sie nicht können mir in
irgendeiner weise eine zusage darüber
machen was das mit meinem körper machen
würde denn klar ist nur eins klar ist
nur dass es gegebenenfalls sehr schwere
nebenwirkungen geben kann die
möglicherweise viel schlimmer sind als
die korona erkrankung mit zwei tagen
fieber jemals sein könnten vielen dank
frau schmidt möchten sie ja wieder
[Applaus]
mit großer freude denn erst mal kann ich
dem kollegen sagen sie haben ihre im
pflicht erfüllt mit zwei impfungen
einmal gelesen haben sie alles das was
wir in unserer gesetz geschrieben waren
erreicht und ich sehe es geht ihnen gut
das freut mich nochmal zur aufklärung
unsere impfpflicht bezieht sich auf drei
impfung oder zwei impfungen und einer
genesung weil das dann nicht davor
schützt dass man sich nicht nochmal
anstecken kann weil das aber davor
schützt dass man schwer erkrankt oder
daran stirbt
und weil wir dann in eine lage kommen
die in der gesamten gesellschaft für
eine grundimmunisierung sorgt dass wir
keine maßnahmen mehr brauchen sondern
dass wir anfangen können einen normalen
umgang mit diesem virus zu pflegen das
ist unser zutiefst getragener wunsch
dass wir endlich davon loskommen mit
diesem virus umgehen zu müssen indem wir
andere freiheitsbeschränkungen auf uns
nehmen sondern wir wollen durch die
grundimmunisierung durch drei impfung
zwei impfungen einmal genesen schaffen
dass wir einen normalen umgang mit
anderen viren auch in unserer
gesellschaft tolerieren können und ich
würde mich freuen wenn sie nach ihren
eigenen erfahrungen an dem auch
zustimmen könnten
jetzt rufe ich den nächsten redner aus
auf den kollegen tino sorge für die
fraktion cdu csu
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen liebetrau
kollegin schmidt ich muss sagen das was
sie gesagt haben kann ich nachvollziehen
teilweise ich finde es auch gut dass sie
gesagt haben wir müssen im rahmen der
diskussion auch über eine impfpflicht
pro oder contra oder in welcher
ausführung aus form auch immer wieder
einen normaleren umgang pflegen also
dass das teilen wir als unionsfraktion
und deshalb finde ich es gut dass sie
auch wenn es die letzten meter sind
sagen wir hätten hier in diesem hause
aus dem aus der mitte was wir mehrheit
des parlaments eine mehrheit finden
müssen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und deshalb darf ich nur noch mal um
unseren antrag und muss seinen
kompromissvorschlag aus unionssicht
werben sie haben ja gerade hier
dargestellt dass wir bei der frage der
bekämpfung im herbst vorsorge treffen
müssen wir haben deshalb als union einen
ausgewogenen vorschlag unterbreitet wir
sagen eben man kann bei der frage
impfpflicht ja oder nein nicht sofort
und gleich pauschal entscheidend ich
sage ihnen das ist wie bei der frage
sind sie bist du für die ehe ja oder
nein da kann man nur sagen es kommt
drauf an es muss die richtige frau da
sein es muss der richtige zeitpunkt da
sein und es müssen die umstände passen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und wir
reden hier über eine impfpflicht wo ich
ihnen sage
dass wir momentan
momentan glücklicherweise
sinkende inzidenz sein haben wo wir
momentan in den krankenhausbereich
glücklicherweise keine überlastung
situation haben und wo wir momentan auch
überhaupt nicht wissen was im herbst für
eine variante grassiert wir wissen nicht
ob die impfstoffe im herbst sein so gut
funktionieren wie sie funktionieren
sollten und deshalb haben wir als union
gesagt lasst uns doch zuallererst eine
belastbare datengrundlage machen
stichwort ins register ich finde es gut
dass sie diesbezüglich jetzt auch sagen
wir müssen das machen aber es ist
natürlich kein kompromiss vorschlag wenn
sie in den gesprächen sagen wir sind
bereit das zu machen aber eben
irgendwann weil das der erste schritt
wäre und deshalb sagen dir ins register
damit wir überhaupt erst mal wissen wie
ist denn auch der eu status in der
bevölkerung und zweitens wir müssen
vorsorge für den herbst treffen und
diese vorsorge beinhaltet auch lieber
herr kollege gesundheitsminister dass
wir die impf infrastruktur vorhalten
oder kann es ähnlich sein dass sie in
allen bereichen lockern dass die masken
pflicht aufgehoben wird dass sie sich
aus der finanzierung der impfzentren der
länder zurückziehen wollen und hier
gleichzeitig mit macht eine impfpflicht
auf vorrat möglichst ab 18 durch die
hintertür durchziehen wollen das halten
wir für den falschen weg in die
kolleginnen versorger gestatten sie eine
zwischenmeldung dazwischen frage aus der
fraktion der grünen
bündnis 90 die grünen sehr gerne
sie haben das wort
in mir bitte erläutern wie es gehen
sollen mitten in eine neue welle hinein
die im herbst hoffentlich nicht kommt
aber nach expertenmeinung mit
überwiegender wahrscheinlichkeit kommt
dann eine impf kampagne zu starten die
noch erfolg hat alle experten sagen wir
müssen vorsorge treffen wir müssen jetzt
handeln in der welle in der anstrengende
welle ist es einfach zu spät wenn sie
uns das bitte noch mal erklären wie das
funktionieren soll vielen dank
vielen dank herr kollege für die frage
das gibt mir die möglichkeit mal ein
paar dinge richtig zu stellen also wenn
sie hier sagen alle experten würden das
so sehen dann ist das nicht wichtig wir
haben immer gesagt wir müssen vorsorge
treffen und diese vorsorge treffen heißt
natürlich nicht dass wir jetzt pauschal
eine impfpflicht für alle menschen
beschließen oder in den letzten tagen
haben sie dann von der impfpflicht ab 18
auf 50 jetzt auch 60 umgeschwenkt sagen
aber gleichzeitig alle müssen dringend
sich beraten lassen was nicht nur
bürokratischer irrsinn ich wäre was auch
von den kommunalen spitzenverbänden was
von den kassen abgelehnt wird nein es
geht darum vorsorge zu treffen und wenn
wir wissen dass im herbst möglicherweise
einen eine welle auf uns zukommt dann
ist es doch umso wichtiger jetzt diesen
vorsorge mechanismus den wir vorschlag
in gang zu setzen es geht doch genau
darum wir können doch nicht sagen wir
nutzen ein mittel eine impfpflicht noch
dazu für alle personen wo wir wissen
dass aufgrund glücklicher weise milder
verläuft diese auswirkung des lebens
komplett anders geworden dann müssen wir
so schauen wenn mit überlastung das
gesundheitssystem vermeiden wollen woher
wissen dass nach jetzigem stand punkt
gerade überdurchschnittlich häufig älter
oder wenn sie schwere verläufe haben auf
die intensivstation kommen können wir
doch jetzt nicht pauschal sagen wir
zwingen alle sich beraten zu lassen wir
lassen unabhängig von der dunk upscale
den varianten ob das dann noch so sein
wird jetzt alle info wir wissen dass das
gar kein eigenes mittel ist und die bei
der kollege ich will ihnen auch noch mal
ganz deutlich sagen das irritiert mich
seit wochen dass wir bei der frage der
eingriffe immer so lapidar darüber
hinweggehen naja es ist eben ein
grundrechtseingriff wir reden hier über
abwägung von grundrechten die reden über
eingriffe in die körperliche
unversehrtheit lieber herr kollege und
und das sage ich auch ganz offen in
richtung bundeskanzlerin in richtung
bundesgesundheitsminister ich hätte
erwartet dass bei dieser sensiblen frage
impfpflicht eingriff in grundrechte die
güterabwägung und die argumentation hier
klarer gemacht werden da muss in der
mitte des parlaments gesprochen werden
und da kann man nichts sagen wir nutzen
ein mittel impfpflicht pauschal für alle
in dem wissen dass es zwar irgendwas
bringt ja impfen schützt impfen schützt
individuellen vor schweren verläufen
aber eine pauschale impfpflicht für team
nicht dazu dass wir mögliche überlastung
situation verhindern die wir momentan
gar nicht haben deshalb liebe kollegen
und kollegen stimmen sie doch für
unseren antrag das ist doch der
kompromisse in der mitte liegen wir
haben endlich ab 18
wir haben diejenigen die sagen wir
brauchen da keine impfpflicht und wir
als union haben gesagt lasst uns doch
die
vorsorgemaßnahmen treffen wenn
tatsächlich dieser fall eintreten sollte
was auch wissenschaftler sagen dass das
überhaupt noch nicht für diesen ist ob
tatsächlich im herbst ein gefährlicher
variante kommt aber lasst uns doch
vorsorge treffen und dann müssen wir
noch die impfzentren haben wir müssen
doch dann wissen in dem moment gibt es
diese variante haben die impfstoffe und
da können wir auch hier im parlament in
kürzester zeit entscheiden aber eben
nicht jetzt auf vorrat in dem wissen
dass es nicht das mildeste mittel ist
deshalb liebe kollegen und kollegen
werde ich inständig stimmen sie unserem
antrag zu
und jetzt haben wir in den letzten tagen
quasi auf den letzten metern gehörte ja
warum sei jetzt die union da nicht
kompromissbereit also ich kann ihnen das
an liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
haben seit wochen ein kompromiss auf den
tisch gelegt und sie können doch nicht
ganz sagt erwarten das wenn sie es in
der eigenen hand koalition nicht
rüberkommen eine mehrheit für dieses
thema zu bekommen und wir diese arbeit
machen bei uns in der unions fraktion
muss auch ein breites meinungsspektrum
gibt dass dieser kompromissvorschlag von
ihnen nicht mal ansatzweise diskutiert
wird und dann erwarte ich von ihnen auch
dass sie ernsthaft auf uns zugehen und
nicht sagte lapidar na ja wir machen
eine impfpflicht jetzt das 18 dann ab 50
jetzt ab 60 aber sofort und ins register
irgendwann also insofern auch für
diejenigen die hier noch unentschlossen
sind liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
wissen doch alle es ist ein sehr
komplexes thema wir haben alle
individuelle betroffenheit wir haben
eine meinung wir haben uns alle eine
meinung dazu gebildet wir wissen wie
hoch polarisieren dieses thema in der
gesellschaft diskutiert wird deshalb ist
es doch ein uns mit einem ausgewogenen
kompromiss mit augenmaß die
voraussetzung zu schaffen das im herbst
diese welle ihn nicht kommt oder
bekämpft werden kann und dafür ist unser
vorschlag ein wirklich tragfähigen
kompromiss vorschlag wir strecken ihnen
die hand entgegen greifen sie diese
handelsstimmung kompromissvorschlag zu
werden überhaupt herbst gewappnet sein
in diesem sinne danke für ihre
unterstützung und vielen vielen dank
liebe kollegin auch
dass wir das was wir den debatten immer
gesagt haben ich habe es in einer
debatte gesagt wir sollten uns die tür
zur versöhnung offen halten liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und egal wie
unterschiedlich die meinung sein möchten
wir haben als und nun einen vorschlag
unterbreiten den strecken in die hatten
aus stimmen sie diesen vorschlag zu dann
werden wir für den herbst gut gewappnet
sein können die debatte befrieden und
die polarisierung aus der gesellschaft
in vielen herzlichen dank
nächste rednerin für die fdp fraktion dr
alles weiter
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren das grundgesetz
hat dem zweck die freiheitsrechte der
bürger zu garantieren
unter diesen wichtigen und grundlegenden
rechten rad das recht auf leben und
körperliche unversehrtheit
hervor das ist unsere letzte
verteidigungslinie wenn eine regierung
sich anmaßt dieses höchste recht nach
belieben umzubiegen dann brauchen wir
keinen verfassungsschutz mehr um zu
sagen dass diese regierung
verfassungsfeindlich handelt dem pflicht
ist nicht nur radikal
verfassungsfeindlich
sie ist eine totalitäre anmaßung eine
entwürdigung des individuums der einzig
argumentative gruppe für die impfpflicht
ist eine art kollektive notwehr weil du
mich angeblich mit deinem körper
gefährt ist hast du das recht verwirrt
über diesen frei entscheiden zu dürfen
ich zwinge dich daher zu deinem glück
eine furchteinflößende
sichtweise
brand stellte menschliche körper denn
keine gefahr mehr dar nach der dritten
nach der vierten nach der fünften
impfung wer entscheidet das und wer gibt
dem staat das recht uns zu unserem
angeblichen glück zu zwingen
weil der befürworter klüger sind als der
rest
ausgerechnet die erste berufsgruppe die
von der freiheitsfeindlichen impfpflicht
betroffen ist sind ärzte krankenpfleger
altenpfleger die im übrigen den schaden
ihren job kündigen
also diejenigen die das größte wissen
haben es geht also nicht um wissen um
das abwägen von rechtsgütern sondern um
die luft an der uneingeschränkten
verfügungsgewalt schon der lock down war
eine politik vorbei am faktischen nach
unserer freiheit ist jetzt unser körper
an der reihe
die erwachsene sind keine konventionelle
impfstoffe sondern ein quantensprung in
der wissenschaft keiner dieser
wirkstoffe hat eine reguläre zulassung
das sind millionen teuren werbekampagnen
als pigs zu verbuchen ist eine
infantilisierung der bürger die eine
rechtliche entmündigung vorweg reich
berechtigte bedenken werden nicht
argumentativ sind am pseudo moralisch
begegnet der einzig rational
nachvollziehbare grund für eine
impfpflicht sind die millionen impfdosen
auf dem professor lauterbach sitzen
bleibt das aber sind die probleme eines
überforderten
gesundheitsministers nicht unsere die
regierung trifft entscheidungen ohne
zuverlässige daten grundlage es gibt
keine belastbaren zahlen zum impfstatus
zunehmenden wirkung oder zu
hospitalisierung tragen
hinzu kommt dass mittlerweile sogar
doppelt geimpfte in der statistik als
ungeimpft gelten wenn ihre letzte
impfung ein halbes jahr zurückliegt ein
impfstatus für ein halbes jahr da gibt
es jetzt die regierung zu dass die
impfung nicht taut
st auch bei der erfassung von
impfnebenwirkungen
es mehren sich die zeichen und ich
möchte dass sie das ernst nehmen hier es
mehren sich die zeichen für eine
dramatische unter erfassung von
gravierenden gesundheitsschäden durch
die neuartigen m erwachsene diese fälle
sind keinesfalls
die universitätsklinik marburg eröffnete
eigens eine spezialambulanz die
überläuft dort gibt es wartelisten von
über 800 patienten hunderte e-mails am
tag das unwürdige impfpflicht geschacher
der ampel ist deshalb nicht nur blamabel
es ist verantwortungslos
sie wolle mit ihrem endlich gesetzt das
gesundheitsministerium ermächtigen jede
gesetzesänderung ohne abstimmung im
bundestag durchzuführen die impfpflicht
ab 60 dient ihm lediglich als
trojanisches pferd sie ist in
wirklichkeit die impfpflicht für alle
verlogener geht es nicht
nächster redner ist wolfgang kubicki für
die gruppe projekte und andere
auch präsident der liebe kollegin
kollegen ist natürlich schwer nach einem
solchen debattenbeitrag darauf nicht
einzugehen aber die zeit an warum es mir
leider nicht denn ich bin auch drei
minuten begrenzt wir können das an
anderer stelle machen
ich kann gut nachvollziehen und besorge
ich kann gut nachvollziehen dass
emotionen bei diesem thema hochgehen
gleichzeitig müssen wir aber aufpassen
dass im eifer des gefechts nicht
argumente benutzt werden die weniger auf
evidenz zurückzuführen sind als auch den
unbedingten willen die eigene position
durchzusetzen
abseits von politischen bewertungsfragen
müssen wir im parlamentarischen prozess
dafür sorgen falsche begründungen als
solche zu identifizieren und das
argumente aus der debatte heraus zu
nehmen und deshalb sollten wir mit blick
auf die anhörung im gesundheitsausschuss
folgende punkte festhalten eine
herdenimmunität wird durch die impfung
nicht erreicht eine deutlich
gefährlichere variante im kommenden
herbst ist nicht das wahrscheinlichste
szenario
ungeimpfte sind nicht schuld daran dass
sich andere menschen infizieren wir
hatten keine überlastung das
gesundheitssystem sie und werden
voraussichtlich auch keine bekommen
die einführung einer allgemeinen
impfpflicht mit einem nur bedingt
zugelassen dem stock ist
verfassungsrechtlich ohnehin ein problem
impfungen gegen dem selbstschutz und
nicht im fremd chance wenn wir uns auch
diese punkte verständigen können darf es
aus verfassungsrechtlichen gründen keine
impfpflicht geben es ist nämlich nicht
die aufgabe des staates erwachsenen
menschen gegen ihren willen zum
selbstschutz zu finden
tauss hat eine vorbildfunktion für die
kultur in unserem land deshalb darf es
nicht darum gehen am ende eine
abstimmung als vermeintliche sieger oder
verlierer dazustehen ist uns darum wer
am ende die rechtlich und
gesundheitspolitisch beste sowie die
gesellschaftlich verträgliche lösung
gefunden zu haben und hier können die
menschen erwarten dass neue erkenntnisse
auch zu einer revision der alten
position führen wenn die data variante
fiel in diesem hause zum umdenken in
sachen impfpflicht gebracht hat dann
muss das auftreten der melderekord
variante konsequenterweise ebenfalls zu
einem umdenken führen
die menschen
könne nachvollziehen dass bei einer
verschärfende situation auch schärfere
politische maßnahmen gefordert werden
wenn diese schärferen maßnahmen aber
auch gefordert werden obwohl ich dazu
sich entspannt hat dann stellt sich die
frage ob es wirklich noch mal eine
sachgerechte politische lösung oder ehe
darum geht die politische deutungshoheit
zu behalten ihre kollegen kollegen
der ethiker auf dem sie ja soviel immer
wieder berufen und empfehle ich empfehle
die 161 seiten des ethikrats mal zu
lesen der ethikrat weil in dieser woche
eine bemerkenswerte stellungnahme zu
vergangenen und künftigen organisation
mit der korona pandemie abgegeben er
formulierte unter anderem und ich
zitiere wenn die von einer pandemisch
auftretende infektionskrankheit
ausgehenden gesundheitlichen risiken
durch impfungen medikation immunisierung
durch vorausgegangen der infektionen
oder auch infolge der verbreitung neuer
virus varianten mit höherer
infektiosität aber geringere
pathogenität unterhalb dessen liegen was
die gesellschaft im hinblick auf andere
viruserkrankungen hinzunehmen bereit ist
lassen sich schwerwiegende freiheits
eingriffe nicht mehr rechtfertigen
zitate nehmen
deshalb frau präsidentin mein letzter
satz
deshalb ist eine allgemeine impfpflicht
ob 18 oder 60 widerrechtlich noch
gesellschaftspolitisch zu rechtfertigen
ich danke für die aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die gruppe während
janitschek und andere ist der kollege dr
andrew ullmann
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ziel unseres gesetzentwurfs ist ganz
klar wir wollen vorsorge treffen und wir
wollen kein dritter corona im vorchor
winter erleben wie wir es letztes jahr
vorletztes jahr erlebt haben wir wollen
endlich frei sein in dem wir auch unser
gesundheitssystem stütze und lieber
wolfgang es geht uns hier nicht um
selbstschutz sondern es geht um
fremdschutz wir wollen unser
gesundheitssystem vor überlastung
schützen das funktioniere nur wenn eine
modernisierung
wir stehen vor einem entscheidungs
dilemma nichtsdestotrotz eine vorhersage
die die welle im winter aussehen wird
können wir seriös eigentlich nichts
vorhersagen gewissen die welle kommt
aber die qualität dieser welle kennen
wir wirklich nicht dass ähnlich wie bei
einer wettervorhersage aber dass sie
kommentiert ist klar wir brauchen noch
bessere datengrundlagen das ist auch
keine frage und diese werden wir auch
bekommen und werden doch entsprechen
diese auch berichten lassen aber was
sollen wir jetzt machen um diesen
nächsten winter in einer katastrophe
nicht enden zu lassen nichts machen
stand der dinge heute ist das sicherlich
eine möglichkeit wäre aber ein
pokerspiel das haben wir letztes jahr
bereits erlebt nix machen hat dazu
geführt dass wir wieder an corinna
winter hatten das wollen wir nicht
wir wollen auch nicht aus dem bauch
heraus in eine entscheidung treffen weil
es sich gut anfühlt nein wir wollen ein
wissenschaftlich fundierte gegenmittel
einbringen dieses gegenmittel ist ganz
klar in flüssen denn nur so kommen wir
durch die nächsten winter
dann stellt sich die frage wie gut reden
brachte bislang wenig im pflichtjahr da
müssen wir aber natürlich prüfen
inwieweit auch mildere möglich mildere
mittel möglich sind das ist eine
professionelle ärztliche aufklärung der
ungeimpften die bürgerinnen und bürger
sind
aufklärungswürdig und sind auch
vernünftig und so können wir auch unsere
in sputen erhöhen unser ursprünglicher
gesetzentwurf aus unserer gruppe wollte
dies aber wir waren die kleinste gruppe
wir hatten keine mehrheit und wir hatten
sie auch nicht haben wiederholt versucht
kontakte zu machen hat leider nicht
funktioniert aber die mehrheit der
antragssteller monat darsteller unserer
gruppe wollte heute nachmittag nicht mit
leeren händen dasteht sollen wir waren
kompromissbereit wir haben einen
kompromiss gesucht wir sind auf die
gruppe der allgemeine impfpflicht gruppe
zugegangen wir als gruppe der
aufklärungspflichten haben ein
kompromiss gefunden in den teilen ist es
natürlich auch schmerzhaft weil unsere
idee wir immer noch für die bessere
halten aber wir können natürlich nicht
ohne irgendetwas heute nach mehr da
stehen und deswegen möchte ich danke
sagen für die verhandlungsgruppe und
auch die kollegen kollege unsere
ursprünglichen gruppe
[Applaus]
zwischenbemerkungen oder frage aus der
deflation
das ist durchaus therapeutisch dann
fühlen sich unter ich las es dazu
so welcher kollege war es denn von ihnen
beiden ist man sofort okay sie haben das
wort
ich möchte sie
als 72 jähriger
der sich nicht hat impfen lassen
und bis heute durch die pandemie die
sogenannte durchgekommen ist ohne
irgendetwas groß zu haben ich hatte vor
drei wochen
und nicht für zwei sondern für drei tage
diese omikron variante und war dann
wieder heile und konnte dann in sachsen
anhalts mich testen lassen und die sache
war erledigt ich war nicht krank aber
ich habe leute gesehen die so standen
nach der impfung die wochenlang
behandelt werden mussten nehmen sie zur
kenntnis wie viele menschen es gibt die
deswegen angst haben vor dieser impfung
weil diese impfung auch viele menschen
krank macht und es gibt gutachten das
0,4 prozent der leute die geimpft werden
0,4 prozent mit dem tode sogar bedroht
sind wie können sie dann über eine
allgemeine impfpflicht überhaupt noch
sprechen beim solchen
grundrechtseingriff ich fahre sie auch
davon abstand zu nehmen und kripo klasse
regeln dass wir in deutschland ein
freiheitliches land sind und dass wir
ein rechtsstaat sind und eine kreishaus
überbelastung hast überhaupt nicht
gegeben entschuldigen sie bitte dass ich
so heftig werden aber ich mache mir
sorgen die impfung kann ich mich auch
mich umbringen wenn ich die machen muss
und ich werde mich auf keinen fall
impfen lassen das sage ich ihnen
wirklich da zahle ich lieber ein bußgeld
schluss aus hören sie auf damit lassen
sie die menschen in freiheit leben
kollege bleiben sie bitte kollege
bleiben sie bitte stehen
danke aber sie dürfen sich auch
hinsetzen was sie bisher erreicht und
das ist vielleicht auch besser wenn
ich möchte ich finde es ja einige
wichtige punkte eingebracht wie will man
konstruktiv an die sache rangehen sie
haben ihre eigene beobachtung mit ihrem
eigenen körper gemacht so läuft
klinische wissenschaft leider nicht weil
das
[Applaus]
ich freue mich riesig dass sie mit ihrem
alter mit 72 ankurbelt interaktion so
milde durchgemacht haben das wissen wir
auch dass gibt auch die wissenschaft her
80 prozent der menschen haben einen sehr
milden verlauf und das ist auch gut so
und das ist auch mal spielt durchaus
roulette damit oder pokalspielen ist es
nicht gut zu spielen ballistik sich
impfen lassen möchte oder nicht aber
eine sache muss man hier klar sagen wir
haben jetzt nicht eine allgemeine
impfpflicht hier in unserem kompromiss
stehen sollen wir haben eine impfpflicht
ab 60 als kompromisslösung gemacht mit
scharfstellung oktober
darf ich mal zu ende sprechen ich habe
ihn ja auch aufs ende sprechen lassen
und somit haben sie eine möglichkeit und
wir haben auch die möglichkeit zu sagen
wenn die korona krise so weiter läuft
bisher und auch die whu sagt ja durchaus
ist könnte milder werden können indem
ich schon verlauf haben aber dafür sind
jedoch ihrem und es darf so entscheiden
die pflicht da ist doch kein problem wir
können das jederzeit entscheiden nur
jetzt müssen wir uns vorbereiten aber
dieser winter nicht fest wo du mir
im moment noch nicht fertig sie haben ja
auch gesagt leute haben angst vor dem
volk das ist genau der punkt die leute
die angst und sorge haben vor der
impfung nehme ich als arzt sehr ernst
die müssen aber aufgezehrt nicht durch
ihre bücher
prima gruppen oder der rest ist facebook
gruppen oder sms die man bekommt oder
telegramm gruppe aus der afg sondern
eine professionelle
und dann kommen da auch hierbei aber
einfach so behauptet dass die impfung
unsere freiheit zerstört ist wirklich zu
kurz gesprungen ist ein bisschen blind
in der menschheitsgeschichte
was bisher immer so eine pandemie endet
dann eine bevölkerung immunisiert ist
und die ionisierung in der
menschheitsgeschichte war immer tod und
krankheit damit verbunden die haben
jetzt erstmalig in der
menschheitsgeschichte die möglichkeit
mit einer impfung diese teufelskreis zu
durchbrechen
und sie setzen ihre freiheit sagen das
ist meine freiheit ich halte ich nichts
von gesellschaftlicher verantwortung
denn sie von freiheit sprechen sich
qualitative freiheit sprechen nicht eine
sammlung von ihren feinheiten
in unserem antrag und das biete ich
jetzt auch an steht tatsächlich die
aufklärungspflicht an erster stelle ich
bin sehr dankbar dass die gruppe und
seine gang gekommen ist im pflicht haben
wir für die besonders wohlhabenden unter
60 jahren mit schaafs team oktober der
bundestag erhält regelmäßig
wissenschaftliche berichte über stand
der pandemie globaler von national- und
somit auch die möglichkeit der
aussetzung oder auch erweiterung der
impfpflicht und das ist weitsicht mit
weiß ich kommen wir vor der welle und
lieber unions kolleginnen kollegen es
gibt keine blaupause in der pandemie
bekämpfung nur gemeinsam können wir
diese pandemie bekämpfen reißen sie die
mauer und des partei straße schon reißen
sie die mauer des pastors es ein und
lassen sie ihr gewissen sprechen unser
gesetzentwurf ist ein angebot an sie
alle dankeschön
[Applaus]
die nächste rednerin ist die kollegin
nina waren für die cdu/csu-fraktion
frau präsidentin werte kolleginnen und
kollegen wir müssen heute darüber
sprechen wie wir unser land und unser
gesundheitssystem auf die kommenden
monate vorbereiten und ich muss ehrlich
sagen es wäre schon wünschenswert
gewesen wenn die debatte und das
verfahren in dieser wichtigen frage
anders gelaufen wäre
stattdessen ist doch ein gewisses wir
war entstanden das wirrwarr hat damit
begonnen als sich die
regierungsfraktionen in gruppenanträge
geflüchtete haben statt ihrer
verantwortung gerecht zu werden und mit
einer stimme einen tragfähigen
gesetzentwurf einzubringen
dass sie mit diesem vorgehen nicht
weiterkommen und die gefahr besteht dass
sie am ende ohne eine lösung da stehen
waffen beginn an absehbar und ein völlig
falsches signal und wo wir schon beim
falschen signalen sind möchte ich doch
auch einmal sagen herr kollege
lauterbach dass es aus meiner sicht
angebrachter gewesen wäre in der
aktuellen lage werden die verhandlungen
laufen mit den kollegen gemeinsam um
einen mehrheitsfähigen gesetzentwurf zur
innenstadt wieder bis spät in die nacht
bei markus lanz zu sitzen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir als cdu csu waren nicht untätig
anders als sie haben wir vor wochen
einen der aktuellen lage angemessenes
konzept vorgeschlagen hinter dem steht
unsere fraktion und von dem sind wir
überzeugt wo keine klare linie erkennbar
bei ihrem lavieren in den letzten tagen
das in der sache schon unwürdig war von
einem vorschlag von einer impfpflicht
für über 50-jährige und einer
impfpflicht ab 18 ist ein vorschlag
einer impfpflicht ab 60 geworden wie das
rechenbeispiel noch zu vermitteln ist
weiß ich auch nicht und wo da eine
güterabwägung stattgefunden haben soll
erschließt sich mir auch nicht
wir lassen uns lieber herr kollege dr
ullmann auch nicht vorwerfen dass wir
nicht kompromissbereit waren oder dass
wir hier allein aus parteitaktischen
gründen und ihrem vorschlag nicht mit
hinein wir gehen aus guten gründen nicht
mit unser antrag ist aus unserer sicht
der beste weil er der einzige ist der
lage um sachgerecht ist er bietet auf
alle günstigen entwicklungen
der pandemie eine antwort hier und heute
eine impfpflicht zu einem festen datum
zu beschließen ist der aktuellen lage
verfrüht und unverhältnismäßig wären
mildere mittel zur pandemie für
bekämpfung wie die masken pflicht
einfach auslaufen lässt der kann heute
parallel dazu keinen tiefgreifenderen
grundrechtseingriff in form einer
impfpflicht einführen
impfen ist zwar nur ein pieks aber es
ist auch ein körperlicher eingriff und
eben nicht lapidar daher muss sorgfältig
abgewogen werden und das tun sie nicht
und damit hat sich die ampel selbst in
eine sackgasse der rechtsunsicherheit
manövriert die impfung schützt
ebenso schützt insbesondere vor schweren
verläufen allerdings droht momentan
keine überlastung des gesundheitssystems
deshalb ist aus unserer sicht aktuell
keine impfpflicht angezeigt aber wir
müssen vorbereitet sein vorbereitet
falls der pandemie verlauf zum beispiel
durch eine tödliche variante eine
impfpflicht erforderlich macht und
deshalb müssen wir schon heute ein
rechtssicheres gesetz schaffen das die
voraussetzungen für einen passgenauen
impf mechanismus der zukunft
sicherstellt dass genau liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen tut unser
antrag ist eben keine starre impfpflicht
auf vorrat die aufgrund der heute
unklaren pandemie entwicklung völlig
ungeeignet ist liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen backen starten sie noch auch
wenn sie nur eigentlich nur noch drei
sekunden hätten aber eine zwischenfrage
aus der spd-fraktion gern herr rose man
ja frau kollegin wagen ist vielen dank
dass zwischen frage zu lassen vielleicht
können sie ja die frage
beantworten die der kollege von bündnis
90 die grünen vorher dem herrn sorge
gestellt hat die er überhaupt nicht
beantworten konnte
sie sprechen ja von
vorsorge passt zum namen ihres kollegen
aber hat passt leider nicht zu dem
antrag also erklären sie mir doch mal
erklären sie doch mal wie sie wie sie
eigentlich sicherstellen wollen dass
wenn ihre impfpflicht vorsorge die
eventuell dann greifen soll wenn die
krankenhäuser schon voll sind dann soll
sie in kraft treten dann beginnt es dann
müssen die bürgerinnen und bürger drei
impfungen durch machen die mit einem
gewissen abstand ja durchgeführt werden
müssen erklären sie doch mal wie diese
dieses verfahren tatsächlich
vorsorge sein soll wenn das am ende erst
greift also die leute erst dann geimpft
sind wenn die welle dann schon wieder
rum ist
glauben kollegen die frage müssen sie
sich selbst stellen ob sie mit dem was
sie hier vorschlagen in der aktuellen
welle auch irgendetwas bewirken können
überhaupt zum einen zum anderen
zum anderen kann ich kann ich nur noch
einmal betonen dass herr kollege sorge
dass er glaube ich schon den zieht ihr
dargelegt hat und man einfach auch mal
den antrag lesen kann das würde glaube
ich helfen
ihn zu verstehen
und es hilft uns am ende auch kein
gesetz das dann von karlsruhe wieder
kassiert wird weil es nämlich zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt
unverhältnismäßig ist weil der
grundrechtseingriff eben nicht
gerechtfertigt ist zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt und sie haben sich ja ziemlich
schwer getan mit der einführung zb eines
im krieg ist das was aus unserer sicht
essenzielle voraussetzung ist um
überhaupt auch mal eine datenlage zu
haben auf die man dann aufsetzen kann
auf die man die menschen auch gezielt
anschreiben kann dann ist nämlich auch
keine beratungspflicht für diejenigen
leute die eh schon sagen ich lasse mich
nicht impfen da brauche ich auch keine
beratungspflicht man muss aber gezielt
menschen an schreiben auffordern
informieren deswegen haben wir auch
gesagt ist im register wichtig da haben
sie sich ja lange gesperrt und haben das
aus datenschutzgründen und was auch
immer
abgelehnt aber man braucht eben solche
mechanismen um vorbereitet zu sein und
das sagen wir wir müssen uns vorbereiten
müssen besser vorbereitet sein und
deswegen unser antrag der jetzt schon
die weichen stellt dann wenn es soweit
ist tatsächlich umgesetzt zu haben das
dann auch rechtssicher ist ein gesetztes
zwar jetzt verabschiedet wird aber am
ende nicht keine wirkung entfalten kann
weil es von den gerichten wieder
kassierte wird das hilft uns glaube ich
überhaupt nicht
ich darf aber abschließend frau
präsidentin noch einmal befragen und der
kollege sorge hat auch schon betont die
union bleibt gesprächsbereit lassen sie
uns doch gemeinsam versuchen noch eine
gute lösung und einen guten kompromiss
für unser land zu finden herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die gruppe behrens
janitschek und andere ist der kollege dr
jahren ausstarben
liebe kolleginnen
liebe kollegen sorge vielleicht lasse
nämlich mit einer bemerkung vorab
staaten demokratie besteht nicht daraus
dass man einen wirkungslosen
halbfertigen antrag in den raum wirft
dann die tür verschließen nicht mehr ans
telefon geht sondern demokratie besteht
daraus ein gesetzesentwurf vorzulegen in
verhandlungen zu gehen kompromisse zu
schließen und hier im parlament das
haben sie in vier monaten nicht
hinbekommen
nach vier monaten intensiver debatte in
der gesellschaft und im parlament zur
frage ob es eine impfpflicht als
vorsorgen das instrument raus aus der
pandemie geben soll ist heute der tag
der entscheidung ich lege mit vielen
abgeordneten aus oppositionsfraktionen
und den regierungsfraktionen einen
funktionierenden gesetzesentwurf vor der
eine impfpflicht ab 60 im kern vorsieht
der wirksam ist der rechtssicher ist und
der vernünftig ist als arzt möchte ich
ihnen sagen weil die frage grad nochmal
aufkamen dass die altersgrenze dabei
keineswegs willkürlich ist sondern mit
medizinischer bedacht und evidenz
gezogen ist zwischen 50 und 60 jahren
steigt das risiko für einen schweren
verlauf noch einmal extrem an das heißt
eine impfpflicht ab 16 erfüllt 60
erfüllt zwei ziele zum einen schützt es
die besonders gefährdeten menschen und
es schützt unser gesundheitssystem ver
neuerlicher überlastung und uns alle vor
einem weiteren pandemie herzens winter
deshalb verdient dieser gesetzesentwurf
ihre stimmen liebe kolleginnen kollegen
die pandemie ist eine von mehreren sind
vulkan krisen mit denen wir in unserer
zeit aktuell konfrontiert ist und die
beste krisenpolitik ist krisenprävention
nach zwei jahren pandemie nach
flutkatastrophe nach energie
abhängigkeit von einem russischen
diktator möchte ich mir in der
gesundheitspolitik nicht mehr vorwerfen
lassen keine vorsorge getroffen zu haben
vorsorge heiß dafür zu sorgen dass die
pandemie im herbst und winter nicht
wieder unser öffentliches leben lahm
legt vorsorge heißt heute zu handeln um
die freiheit von morgen zu sichern die
prävention mit der impfpflicht bringt
uns raus aus dieser pandemie aus guten
gründen soll es bei dieser medizin
ethischen frage keine fraktionsdisziplin
geben wenn ich aber nun höre dass
unionsabgeordnete intern schriftlich
aufgefordert werden nicht über
impfpflicht ab 60 mit ja zu stimmen dann
habe ich den eindruck die union benimmt
sich bei einer besonderen gewissen phase
besonders gewissenlos neben dem virus
das menschenleben tötet gibt es in der
politik offensichtlich ein virus der
parteitaktik und dieses virus der
parteitaktik tötet das vertrauen in
demokratische institutionen wir haben
alle in diesem parlament eine gemeinsame
verantwortung für dieses land gegenüber
den menschen die mehrheitlich weiterhin
nach vier monaten eine impfpflicht
wollen wir haben die verantwortung jetzt
vorsorge für den herbst zu tragen liebe
union auch sie stehen in der
verantwortung besinnen sie sich darauf
und stimmen sie für den gesetzesentwurf
der vorliegt
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fraktion der afd
martin sichert
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
ein echter demokrat macht nach der wahl
was er vor der wahl versprochen hat
heute
heute ist der tag an dem die bürger
sehen welche abgeordneten demokraten
sind vor der bundestagswahl hat jede der
im bundestag vertretenen parteien den
wählern versprochen dass es keine
impfpflicht geben wird jede einzelne
hier vertretene partei hat dieses
versprechen im wahlkampf gegeben für uns
von der afg ist die demokratie grundlage
unseres handelns als überzeugte
demokraten
als überzeugte demokraten werden wir
nach der wahl halten was wir vor der
wahl versprochen haben in dem wir
geschlossen gegen eine impfpflicht
stimmen
es ist an der zeit all die lügen zu
beenden auf denen die gesamte politik
fust justizminister buschmann lockt als
er sagte dass zum 20 märz alle maßnahmen
enden werden maßnahmen sind noch da
gesundheitsminister lauter machtlos als
er ende oktober sagte dass es keinen
booster für alle brauche und er drei
wochen später den booster für alle
forderte einfache abgeordnete wie emilia
fester logan als sie verkündete dass sie
nicht im ausland war obwohl sie urlaub
in dänemark gemacht hat aber
aber wie kann man es den bundestags
küken zum vorwurf machen wenn selbst der
bundeskanzler liegt olaf scholz schlug
als er im dezember erklärte dass die
regierung nichts von schweren
nebenwirkungen der impfung erfahren habe
zu dem zeitpunkt waren laut der
bundesregierung knapp 30.000 fälle
schwerer nebenwirkungen registriert das
ist immerhin die bevölkerung einer
mittelgroßen stadt
herr scholz ist nicht da ist zu beginn
meiner rede anscheinend geflüchtet aber
ich denke mal er schaut heimlich draußen
im fernsehen zu herr scholz sie haben
den bürgern vor der bundestagswahl
gesagt zitat wir brauchen keine
impfpflicht wollen sie wirklich auch
dieses wahlversprechen brechen und als
lügen kanzler in die geschichte eingehen
ja die nächste lüge die nächstenliebe
kam von jens spahn der sagte nämlich die
impfung sei ordentlich zugelassen das
ist die impfung bis heute nicht es gibt
nur eine bedingte zulassung der ema die
bis
2024 eine ordentliche zulassung prüft
jeder der ein medikament nimmt das nur
bedingt zugelassen ist der nimmt an
einem medizinischen experiment teil und
ein medizinisches experiment ein
medizinisches experiment darf niemals
verpflichtend sein dass
das sagt nicht nur die allgemeine
erklärung der menschenrechte in die
europäische grundrechte charta das
grundgesetz sondern das sollte auch
jeder bundestagsabgeordnete aus der
deutschen geschichte gelernt haben daher
fordert sie alle auf
daher fordere ich sie alle auf schließen
sie sich uns an zeigen sie dass ihnen
die demokratie was wert ist und stimmen
sie gegen die impfpflicht
bevor ich den nächsten redner aufrufe
kollege sichert werde ich sie jetzt für
zwei dinge rühmen sie haben einmal
gesagt weil es zwei persönliche angriffe
gegeben hat und das will ich jetzt auch
nochmal einmal erklären sie haben einmal
die kollegin emilia fester als
bundestags küken bezeichnet das ist eine
vermögen sie lachen das ist aber ein
angriff in der person und eine display
zierliche äußerung dafür ruhig sie hier
und das zweite ist sie haben den
bundeskanzler in der person als lügner
bezeichnet auch dass auch das ist ein
angriff das ist ein angriff auf die
person und auch dafür erteile ich ihnen
eine rüge
es ist ein das diskutierte zugänglich
sondern dass es hier mit noch mal
festgehalten und jetzt rufe ich
demnächst die nächsten redner auch für
die gruppe behrens und janáceks dr karl
lauterbach
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen zunächst einmal sehr viele
zögern hier im haus ob eine impfpflicht
noch notwendig ist weil die omikron
variante milder verläuft als frühere
varianten ich möchte dazu sagen romy
kommt ist deshalb eine etwas mildere
variante war so viele menschen schon
geimpft sind wenn es nicht so wäre wenn
es nicht so wenn sich alle wenn sich
alle wenn sich alles so verhalten hätten
wir sie zum teil vorgetragen wird und
niemand hätte sich impfen lassen dann
hätten wir jetzt eine lupenreine
katastrophe und während dem völligen
noch das muss man verstehen und
herr kollege kubicki alle varianten die
bisher gekommen sind sind von experten
nicht vorhergesagt worden sie haben uns
aber eben vorgetragen was im herbst
kommt sind sie bescheidener ich schätze
sie ich gebe ihnen literatur die zeit es
sind nur schmeckt sehr gefährliche
varianten möglich wenn die omikron
variante zum beispiel tiefer in die
lungen abschnitte geht das sind nur fünf
oder sechs mutation dann haben wir eine
sehr ansteckende sehr gefährliche warnte
davor haben namhafte kollegen angst und
sie sollten nicht vortäuschen als wenn
sie wissen dass das im herbst nicht der
fall ist
und starten sie eine frage von der
kollegin baum aus der sp fraktion ein
ich möchte ausdrücklich auch darauf
hinweisen
dass wir selbst werden die omikron
variante im herbst zurück käme es kennt
keine andere variante sie würden nicht
gefährlich es wäre genauso wie erst dann
hätten wir im oktober nach allem was die
modelle her gehen ungefähr 200 bis 300
todesfälle wie jetzt wollen wir das
wirklich als gesellschaft akzeptieren
wollen wir uns daran gewöhnen dass jeden
tag 200 300 menschen sterben und wollen
wir uns erzählen dass das einzelne glück
gehabt haben und davon ableiten dass
andere auf der intensiv dass und legen
um ihr leben kämpfen das kann keine
humane gesellschaft für uns
und wir haben ist in der hand ich habe
noch einmal an die kolleginnen und
kollegen in der union wir haben es in
der hand an ihnen wird viele leute
hängen sie können denn das sie können
der verantwortung nicht ausreichend in
dem sie sagen sie sind gesprächsbereit
die gespräche haben über monate
stattgefunden heute ist der tag der
entscheidung lassen sie uns nicht im
schlecht unterstehen sie willig ist
dieser verantwortung werden sie mich
nicht wollen dann sagen sie es wir sind
abgeordnete im parlament von denen ich
nichts oder so gut wie nichts erwarte
sie sagen aber klar was sie wollen aber
sind sie ehrlich sie wollen die
impfpflicht oder nicht wir brauchen
heute einmal ihre staatstragenden
unterstützung um im herbst anders dazu
stehen dass wir jetzt stehen
und ich will zum schluss die wichtigste
zahl sagen die richtig sitzt und jan
abgeordnete haben hat es angedeutet aber
ich sage es und wir sind da einer mal
die wichtigste zahl ist heute 90 prozent
werden wir die impfpflicht ab 60
beginnen dann verhindern wir 90 prozent
der todesfälle die wir mit einer
impfpflicht verändert hätten 18 wir
haben heute die möglichkeit 90 prozent
der todesfälle vermeidbar sind durch an
endlich zu vermeiden nutzen mehr bitte
diese gelegenheit
[Applaus]
bevor ich bevor ich den nächsten redner
aufrufe hat das wort zu einer
kurzintervention
frau dr baum
vielen dank herr lauterbach ich bin 66
jahre und habe bis heute mein leben in
eigenverantwortung verbracht privat wie
wirtschaftlich ich bin zudem zahnärztin
und stehe jeden tag in dem so genannten
spree leben in den aero sohlen und habe
bis heute diese zwei jahre und drei
monate ohne irgendeine infektion
verbracht weil ich ein sehr gutes
eigenes immunsystem haben wir geben
ihnen nun das recht nicht zu entmündigen
nach einem so langen erfolgreichen sehen
werden
und mit welchem gewissen können sie es
überhaupt vereinbaren nachdem sie heute
wissen wieviel schwere nebenwirkungen
und todesfälle ist durch diese impfung
geben wie können sie es überhaupt noch
vereinbaren mit ihrem gewissen und das
frage ich alle anderen abgeordneten auch
wenn mir oder anderen personen die durch
ihren zwang sich jetzt nötigen lassen
diese impfung zu geben wie können sie es
verantworten wenn den personen etwas
passiert oder wenn sie sogar sterben das
möchte ich gerne von ihnen wir sind
dankeschön
herr lauterbach sie möchten erwidern
muss ehrlich sagen ich finde es immer
wieder bestürzend und zum glück ist es
hätten aber ich finde es immer wieder
gestört sind wenn kolleginnen und
kollegen aus der medizin und wie gesagt
es sind wenige ihre reputation als erste
nutzen und etwas zu sagen was vor der
gesamten wissenschaft der welt in abrede
gestellt wird wie wir verlassen uns wir
sind durch diese krise gekommen in dem
wir uns auf die wissenschaft verlassen
haben in denen wir menschen vertraut
haben die fragen gegangen sind und
gerade wir ärzte wir sollten uns zuerst
intern lassen wir sollten mit beispiel
fragen geht denn die menschen vertrauen
uns und dieses vertrauen sollten wir
nicht ausnutzen
nächster redner für die gruppe kubicki
und andere ist max lux
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen aus den
demokratischen fraktionen dieses hauses
sie können ihre lügen hier wider
besseren wissens verbreiten sie werden
nicht verhindern können dass die
demokratischen abgeordneten heute im
respekt voreinander in dieser sehr
schwierigen gewissensentscheidung eine
entscheidung treffen
ich halte es für erforderlich die impf
lücke zu schließen aber ich komme zu der
abwägung
gegen eine impfpflicht zu sein
ist komme
ich komme dazu bei meiner erfahrung als
freund und verwandte dieser pandemie der
in seinem umfeld um die impfung einer
jeden einzelnen personen gekämpft hat
mir zeigt dass es nur dann funktioniert
wenn man dem druck raus nimmt ich halte
die erklärungen glas eine impfpflicht
zur schließung der imf lücke führt nicht
für plausibel denn eine pflicht dauert
normativen druck auf ich halte diesen
normativen druck für den falschen weg
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die impfpflicht spricht vielen menschen
ein pandemie ende per gesetz doch ich
befürchte dass sich dieses versprechen
nicht halten lassen wird stattdessen
wird sie rechtliche gefahren ich mache
mir sorgen dass der ausschluss von
ordnungshaft verfassungsbeschwerden
nicht standhält und individuelle
gesundheitliche gründe durch das
normative raster fallen können die
umsetzung dieser pflicht ist nicht
sichergestellt und ein nicht umsetzbares
gesetzt bringt uns in der pandemie nicht
weiter liebe kolleginnen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben als
parlament und als politikerinnen und
politiker in der frage wie die menschen
vom impfen überzeugen in der frage wie
wir die gesellschaft zusammenhalten nach
dieser und in dieser pandemie so viel
mehr spielräume als nur ordnungsrecht
lassen sie uns diese nutzen lassen sie
uns die impfpflicht zu den akten legen
dankeschön
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin für die gruppe behrens
ja und janitschek und andere ist die
kollegen dr paul j
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir treffen
heute dieses schwierige entscheidung vor
zwei ziemlich einfachen wahrheiten eine
wahrheit ist niemand von uns kann
wirklich vorhersagen wie corona sich in
diesem herbst darstellen wird auch der
gesundheitsminister nicht das komplett
richtig die andere wahrheit ist auch wir
haben den letzten und dem vorletzten
corona herbst verschlafen wir waren
nicht ordentlich vorbereitet und wir
haben deswegen auch die interessen
unserer bevölkerung nicht ausreichend
gut geschützt und das darf uns einfach
nicht noch einmal passieren dann wenn
wir alle in verantwortung genommen
aber wir sehen heute in dieser debatte
in kondensierter form an welchen punkten
auch im letzten und dem vorletzten ja
genau diese vorsorge gescheitert ist im
sommer jetzt gerade wieder im frühling
wenn die wände kroner pandemie nicht das
wichtigste thema ist wenn die
öffentliche aufmerksamkeit nicht
komplett auf dieses thema gerichtet ist
da wird zerredet der wirt parteitaktik
vorgeschoben da wird darauf vertröstet
dass man ja noch zeit hat bis zum herbst
und dann ist es wieder zu spät und
deswegen schauen wir uns mal an was
jetzt heute hier auf dem tisch liegt bei
dem versuch der diesen fehler nicht zum
dritten mal in folge zu machen und ich
las beiseite den schuss von rechts und
ich lasse auch bei seite des ins
politische deppen bermudadreieck um
herrn kubicki vorwand nicht und herr
gysi ich finde da muss man jetzt keine
zeit verschwenden aber dann schauen wir
uns jetzt mal den unionsantrag an der
unterems antrag gestufter
impressionismus was steht bei uns im
gesetzentwurf erst mal eine in sich
tatsächlich kann ausgesetzt werden im
sommer im herbst wenn sie nicht
gebraucht wird kann aber auch zu
gestalten werden das ist gestuft die
union möchte neben register des imf
register fragen steht bei uns im
gesetzentwurf
die union möchte auf der basis von
wissenschaftlichen daten auch zu den
neuen varianten entscheiden da steht bei
uns als wissenschaftlicher bericht für
den herbst genau mit drin die
inhaltlichen unterschiede zwischen ihrem
antrag und unserem gesetzentwurf die
sind so klein die erlauben keine nicht
zustimmung von ihnen die
unterschiede
nicht nur ausnutzen als klippen an denen
die nicht mitziehen können er wird für
die nicht gestimmt wie beschleunigen
können und dann müssen sie herr merz sie
waren nicht dabei aber die meisten ihrer
kollegen haben 16 jahren regiert wenn
man den versucht jetzt wieder frei im
brief die zu bitten den impuls zu
unterdrücken zuzustimmen damit was
herauskommen ich übersetze diesmal sie
bitten ihre fraktion den impuls zu
unterdrücken konstruktiv zu sein das ist
aber die dna der union
und die wollten wieder eins mitgeben
kann ich verstehen aber zugeben nicht
der ampel ein feld zu geben dem ganzen
land einst mit sie geben ihren leuten in
den ländern und den kommunen 1 mit
hendrik wüst
holetschek
und auch daniel günther die haben alle
in den letzten tagen noch mal gesagt das
ist das braucht natürlich können jetzt
mit ihnen noch mal eine runde drehen wir
können noch mal über impfpflicht
kompromisse sprechen aber die zeit läuft
davon und wenn wir irgendwas die letzten
zwei jahre gelernt haben ist dass man
nicht unendlich viel zeit bis zum herbst
wenn man vorbereitet sein starten sie
eine zwischenfrage oder zwischen werken
aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
ich gestatte zwischen frau kollegin sie
haben das wort
vielen dank dass sie die zwischenfrage
zu lassen weil sie jetzt so tun als wir
da keine unterschiede und die union ist
schuld dass sie nicht mitmachen ich
nehme an dass sie keine juristen sind
sondern ärztin und vom herzen des
helfens argumentieren und leider löst
diesen rechtsstaat auch an die
verfassung halten ist ihnen bewusst dass
es einen völligen unterschied gibt
zwischen einführung an der pflicht jetzt
noch nicht verfassungswidrig aber wenn
man eine branche halt wieder aus wir
haben noch nicht die voraussetzung wir
schaffen die voraussetzungen aber wenn
dann die voraussetzungen vorliegen erst
dann kann man durch einen erneuten
parlament beschloss eine impfpflicht
einführen das sind verfassungsrechtlich
dimension
dimensionen und ist unglaublich diese
unterschieden war auch bewusst das ist
unser
bundesverfassungsgerichtes dazu führt
dass all diese gesetze nichtig sind tun
sie nicht so als wäre es völlig
irrelevant des verfassungsrecht es geht
um grundrechtseingriffen
vielen dank für die frage ich ich
entschuldige mich wenn der eindruck
entstanden sein sollte dass ist das
verfassungsrecht ignoriert das tue ich
keinesfalls in den letzten monaten
ausfiel ist auch mit diversen
verfassungsrechtler ihnen gesprochen und
alle haben gesagt letztendlich ist alles
was heute hier auch zur abstimmung liegt
in irgendeiner form vor dem
verfassungsgericht auch argumentierbar
das ist eine politische entscheidung sie
können jetzt hier nicht sie können jetzt
hier nicht das verfassungsrecht
vorschieben die müssen es
auf die worte gewählt vom vielen
menschen gerade ihre partei auch von
älteren menschen die darauf vertrauen
wenn sie im herbst einen herzinfarkt
oder einen schlaganfall haben dass sie
dann dass die dann darauf vertrauen
können dass alles dafür getan wurde dass
das gesundheitssystem da nicht
überlastet ist und sie ohren nicht
versorgen kann und daten werden auf sie
gemessen werden und deswegen noch mal
und damit kommt es auch zum ende das ist
eine entscheidung wo man nicht der ampel
was mit gibt wo man nicht der spd oder
herr lauterbach was mit gibt sondern wo
man dem ganzen land was mit gibt wenn
man jetzt nicht das erkennt was
notwendig ist pragmatismus aktivität und
ich lasse mir auch gerne genauso wie
professoren das wird manchmal zu
pragmatisch sind aber wenn ich mir die
letzten zwei corona jahre anschaue dann
brauchen wir mehr pragmatismus und nicht
weniger
nächster redner ist der kollege erich
irlstorfer für die fraktion cdu schießen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
im grundsatz einig sind wir uns einig
wir wollen die pandemie die siegen und
jetzt geht es darum was der richtige weg
ist und wir haben heute die möglichkeit
dass wir ein vorsorge gesetzt
beschließen dass uns die chance gibt
dass wir es rechtlich dass wir es
handwerklich gut vorbereitet und
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren ich
mag es nicht wenn man hier so in die
glaskugel schaut keiner von uns hat die
gewissheit und weiß es wirklich was den
kommenden herbst und im winter geschehen
würde und
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
unser vorschlag gibt die möglichkeit und
das ist hier ein bisschen zu kurz
gekommen dass die evaluierung der lage
fester bestandteil unseres vorschlags
und
und ich glaube dass es wichtig ist dass
wir ständig informiert werden über die
situation in den krankenhäusern dass wir
ständig informiert werden überlegen
sektion lage dass wir ständig wissen was
den sache ist und dass wir dann
ordentlich entscheiden können und meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren ich
möchte hier schon noch mal auf herrn
doch zusammen und darf auf die frau
doktor gehört da reingehen
sich meisten uns hier vor dass wir
irgend jemand etwas mitgeben wollen oder
dass wir parteipolitisch handeln und
dass es eine gewissensentscheidung ist
meine sehr geehrten haben den herren ich
möchte ihnen schon mal sagen wenn sie
hier diese form der gruppe anträge für
richtig halten ja warum machen sie dann
die gruppen anträge nicht bei anderen
sachen aus der not heraus machen sie
gruppen andere weise sich nicht einig
sind das ist die wahrheit die hier
zurück sehr geehrte damen und herren
und wenn wir dann noch gerade über focus
online hören dass bundeskanzler scholz
berbalk auffordert sie solle doch das
nato-treffen früher verlassen weil sie
zur abstimmung zu impfpflicht kommen
soll naja ich glaube das spricht bände
eben meine verehrten damen
kollege hilflos
ich habe gesehen
ich glaube aus der fraktion der grünen
aber auch aus der fraktion die linke
zwei wünsche nach einer
zwischenbemerkung zwischen frage und
lassen sie die zu selbstverständlich
dann würde ich mit der fraktion mit dem
kollegen aus der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen beginnen
wir haben ja viel gemeinsam wir teilen
uns hier einen wahlkreis und auch die
kommunalpolitische erfahrung vor ort und
was wir lernen wir da dass das ziel im
fokus steht dass wir gemeinsam an einer
sache arbeiten wie bewerten sie denn
dass dieser impuls den ja jeder
politiker jeder politikerin hat das ziel
die sache klarzustellen jetzt
ausgebremst wurde durch ihre politische
geschäftsführung und gesagt wurde auf
keinen fall dürfte konstruktiv
beteiligen am prozess und eine lösung
mitarbeiten in diesen dingen
herr kollege eckhard ich möchte ganz
klar stellen dass und mein vorredner der
sorge auch das ja auch noch mal betont
dass die union jederzeit gesprächsbereit
ist aber es muss natürlich schon vom
willen getragen sein nach das richtige
zu tun dies ist notwendig und bass
leiteten
die zweite war die kollegin vogler aus
der fraktion die linke
lieber kollege irlstorfer sie haben hier
die
regierungskoalition dafür kritisiert
dass sie diese
dieses anliegen in gruppen anträgen
behandelt das habe ich auch getan weil
ich der ansicht bin dass ein
gesetzentwurf für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht durchaus von der
bundesregierung hätte vorbereitet und
vorgelegt werden können aber
das aus ihrem mund kommt mir doch ein
bisschen seltsam vor weil das war doch
gut gelebte praxis der cdu csu fraktion
in verschiedenen in den letzten 16
jahren immer dann wenn sie sich selber
nicht einig waren zwischen der csu und
der cdu zum beispiel oder wenn sie in
der fraktion unterschiedliche
auffassungen hatten auch gruppen
antragsverfahren vorzusehen zum beispiel
bei der organspende da kam mir noch gut
daran erinnern da war ich ja auch daran
beteiligt also ich frage mich wirklich
welche rolle die union als größte
oppositionsfraktion hier in diesem
parlament ein zu nehmen gedenkt wenn die
wenn sie die positiven erfahrungen die
wir doch auch mit diesen gruppen
verfahren teilweise gemacht haben jetzt
wo sie in der opposition sind und wo sie
die rolle des oppositionsführers
schafft an dem nun plötzlich nicht mehr
ernst nehmen und wenn ich dann lese dass
bei ihnen der fraktion der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer
angeordnet hat falls ihr antrag keine
mehrheit findet und jetzt zitiere ich
sollte dem impuls widerstanden werden
anderen vorlagen zuzustimmen nur damit
es irgendein ergebnis gibt ja da frage
ich mich doch wo ist denn da das recht
und die pflicht der abgeordneten sich
aus eigener gewissensentscheidung auch
eine eigene meinung zu arbeiten ich
zeige ihnen
in meinen armen fraktionen haben wir
die auflösung der
unterschiedlichen auffassungen zu den
verschiedenen vorlagen ausgetauscht
miteinander diskutiert und wir werden
sie heute frei entscheiden und frei
abstimmen jede und jeder nach ihrem
gewissen und das muss ihnen doch
körperliche schmerzen bereiten dass die
linksfraktionen da demokratischer ist
und das als die cdu csu fraktion ist
jemals sein kann
frau kollegin vogeler ich konnte so eine
körperliche schmerzen
bereitet wir aktuell lancôme und nicht
hier einen verfahren oder sonst
irgendwas und es kann ihnen nur sagen
dass aufgrund dieser tatsache ich
weiterhin noch einmal bestärkt werden
dass man richtig um vorsichtig handeln
muss und ich kann ihnen nur sagen was
wir hier erleben ist ja schon eine
bizarre situation
sie werfen uns hier jetzt vor dass wir
uns auch stimmen wir sind doch die
einzige fraktion gewesen wo wir selbst
bei uns in der lage waren überhaupt
einen vorschlag zu erarbeiten
passieren stoffs vorwerfen finde ich
seltsam auf jeden fall nehmen es aber
zur kenntnis und ich kann ihnen nur
sagen in der vergangenheit ja da haben
wir auch von diesem instrument gebrauch
gemacht aber wenn sie jetzt sagen dass
dieses eine gewissensentscheidung ist
dann frage ich mich was ich beim § 209
10 aber haben sie nicht brauchen das ist
auch einer keine diese entscheidung also
von daher
und angeblich für die zwischenfrage
möchten natürlich er weiterfahren ich
kann ihnen nur eins sagen das liegt mir
am herzen
es ist die situation so dass wir diese
debatte heute führen und die führen wir
schon spät glaube ich und ich glaube
auch dass wir natürlich einen freak ist
benötigen das ist wichtig das ist
notwendig und wenn wir zu einem ergebnis
kommen würden was eine impfpflicht sie
auf den weg bringen würde dann würde ich
mir schon auch wünschen dass es hier
ausfahrten gibt ausfahrten für menschen
die körperliche schäden haben wo ist
denn hier eine ausnahme regierung wo
sind denn hier die ausnahmen auch für
psychische situationen wo sind die
ausnahmen auch für das thema auf meine
sehr geehrten nahmen werden wir
berücksichtigen wir verschiedene
gruppierungen von menschen überhaupt gar
nicht die vielleicht die familie einen
impfschaden haben und autor angst haben
dass sie sowas erleiden es wird nicht
abgebildet das ist handwerklich nicht in
ordnung meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren
ich möchte nochmals darauf hinweisen
dass wir weder ein virus kennen das für
herbst oder winter
dementsprechend uns vor eine neue
situation sind und dass wir auch noch
keinen impfstoff haben weil wir dass wir
es noch nicht kennen und deshalb lassen
sie uns hier wirklich mit weitblick und
mit augenmaß handeln wir wollen die
menschen schützen und wir wollen mal im
leben schützen das ist das was uns
leitet vielen herzlichen dank
nächste rednerin für die gruppe wären
sie janitschek und andere ist die
kollegin katrin nendingen klar
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren
angst ist ein schlechter ratgeber erst
recht für politiker wir dürfen uns keine
angst machen lassen nicht von virus
pessimisten und auch nicht von corona
leugnen unsere aufgabe ist es die
situation kühl klug und vorausschauend
zu bewerten so dann müssen wir eine
lösung strategie entwickelt und den mut
haben für sie einzutreten nach allem was
wir wissen es wird im kommenden herbst
winter zu einer neuen corona welle
kommen es entstehen ständig auch in
diesem moment neue virusvarianten mit
unterschiedlichsten eigenschaften wenn
sich eine variante durchsetzte
gefährlicher als die jetzige ist dann
werden wir weihnachten wieder vor einer
situation stehen in der viele menschen
schwer erkrankten in der die kliniken
drohen überzulaufen
dann werden beschränkungen des alltags
wieder hochgefahren werden müssen es
wird kontakt beschränkungen und
einschränkungen zu garten von
gastronomie und einzelhandel geben es
kann sein dass bildung und betreuung von
kindern wieder leiden menschen werden
auf dringend notwendige operationen
warten müssen und vieles mehr
man kann vor diesen nicht
unwahrscheinlichen szenario nicht die
augen verschließen
man kann sagen das ist okay für mich ich
lebe damit lassen wir die dinge laufen
dann braucht man unserem gesetzentwurf
nicht zuzustimmen oder man kann sagen
das risiko will ich nicht eingehen
nichts tun das passt mir nicht ich trau
mich vorausschauend zu denken und zu
handeln dann stimmt man unserem
gesetzentwurf zu dem 1 heute zur
abstimmung stehenden konzept gegen einen
weiteren pandemie winter das konzept ist
ein tragfähiger kompromiss das ergebnis
ehrlichen ringens um die beste lösung
mit einer vorgeschalteten richtige
beratung altena die sich noch nicht zur
impfung entscheiden konnten wollen wir
noch einmal mit desinformation und fällt
views auf begeben der individuellen
aufklärung eine chance der impfung sind
der beste individuelle schutz vor den
folgen von cobit vor schweren
krankheitsverläufen und tod mit dem
frühzeitigen beschluss eine impfpflicht
für personen ab 60 jahren beugen wir
einer überlastung des gesundheitssystems
wirksam vor und darüber hinaus
beobachten wir dass pandemie geschehen
wir fassen uns als parlament zuvor
definierten zeitpunkten und stellt so
sicher dass wir stets auf dem pfad der
verhältnismäßigkeit bleiben
diese völlig unschuldigen im winter
behaupten man habe es nicht kommen sehen
kann dieses jahr keiner mehr lassen sie
mich deshalb abschließend ihn mit dem
blick mit blick auf die abstimmung
gleich zu rufen dürfen sie sich nicht
weg auch wenn es gegenwind gibt denn die
sie vorausschauend fassen sie den mut
ihrem gewissen zu folgen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin für die gruppe kubicki
und andere ist die kollegen dr sarah
banken
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen halten wir fest die impfstoffe
schützen nicht davor sich und andere zu
infizieren schwere verläufe sind mit
omikron zum glück so selten geworden
dass selbst trotz rekord inzidenz und
kein krankenhaus überlastet war wie gut
die impfung gegen künftige mutationen
schützt weiß kein mensch und dann häufen
sich auch noch berichte über
nebenwirkungen impfschäden und trotzdem
halten sie unbeirrt daran fest den
menschen eine impfpflicht aufzuzwingen
weil der kanzler durchsetzungsfähigkeit
demonstrieren muss weil ein kopfloser
gesundheitsminister der sich durch sein
erotisches agieren längst unmöglich
gemacht hat zumindest
offenbar
handlungsfähigkeit und gesicht wahren
will die deutschen geisterfahrer gegen
den rest der welt wo kein mensch mehr
über endlich nachdenkt und diskutiert
das kann doch nicht ernst sein und
deshalb meine bitte hören sie auf die
menschen zu bevormunden die korona
impfung muss eine persönliche
entscheidung bleiben
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin für die gruppe behrens
janitschek und andere franziska matschig
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen was wir
hier erleben ist eine ganze menge selbst
fassung und manche sind auch des lesens
nicht so richtig mächtig aber worum geht
es denn ehrlicherweise die ganze
pandemie hat uns zwei jahre lang mit
ganze menge abverlangt besonders
familien kindern jugendlichen ich bin
mutter von vier kindern ich weiß wie es
ist neben der arbeit irgendwie noch
lehrerin zu sagen zwischen familien- und
erwerbsarbeit zerrissen zu werden auch
ältere waren eingeschränkt manchmal sehr
einsam kranke kommt nicht ausreichend
behandelt werden unternehmen mussten
schließen menschen haben ihre arbeit
verloren
das gesellschaftliche leben kunst und
kultur fand nicht mehr statt zwei jahre
lang haben wir alle abstand gehalten
masken getragen kontakte minimiert das
motto war stets flecken de coeur ich
danke all den pflegerinnen und ärztinnen
sowie allen freiwilligen die für ihren
riesigen einsatz nicht nur in der ersten
phase der pandemie sondern bis heute
dafür gesorgt haben dass unser
gesundheitssystem nicht zusammenbricht
und auch ohne die maßnahmen hätten wir
das alles nicht geschafft immer wieder
immer wieder diese einschränkungen der
grundrechte rechte und ausgebranntes
krankenhauspersonal das muss doch jetzt
mal vorbei sein und es kann vorbei sein
denn wir haben die mittel in der hand
wir haben fast alle fast alle die
möglichkeit uns impfen zu lassen doch
nicht alle nutzen sie also sind wir
heute hier und diskutieren über eine
impfpflicht ich danke unseren
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach und
unseren bundeskanzler olaf scholz dass
sie diese so herausfordernde frage in
die hände des parlaments gelegt haben
es ist lachen sie nur es ist die pflicht
um das wie kann die cdu jeder und jedes
einzelnen abgeordneten sach und
lösungsorientiert
abgestimmt und unabhängig vom parteibuch
es ist eine gewissensentscheidung
die abgeordneten werden diskutiert wir
haben diskutiert nicht nur miteinander
sondern ganz besonders mit bürgerinnen
und bürgern und zwar sehr lebhaft und
sehr zu sehr unterschiedlichen
interessen
die debatte im parlament spiegelt das
heute glaube ich ganz gut wieder aber
unsere aufgabe als abgeordnete ist es
doch all diese interessen abzuwägen und
die impfung ist ein wichtiger schritt zu
gewohnter normalität gegen cobit 19
gifte menschen haben nachweislich
mildere krankheiten leute oder er kann
vielleicht gar nicht mehr und sie
bewahren unser gesundheitssystem vor
einer überlastung darum geht es die
schützen kommt
lebensbereichen starken einstellungen
wie der alle gemeinsam zwei jahre lang
getragen haben doch auch die persönliche
freiheit ist ein hohes gut genauso wie
das gesellschaftliche miteinander und
ein funktionierendes gesundheitssystem
und zwar für alle die es brauchen darum
genau darum entscheidet unser
gesetzentwurf eine beratungs oder
impfnachweis licht für alle bürgerinnen
ab 18 und wir beraten auch diese
entscheidung kann man dann seine eigene
seine eigene entscheidung für eine info
treffen besonders wohlhabender gruppen
aber also menschen ab 60 müssen jedoch
eine info schweiz nicht vorzeigen und
der bis zum herbst nachkommen damit
übernehmen sie verantwortung und
verdienen auch weitere
grundrechtseingriffe das virus ist da
das virus wird bleiben lassen sie uns
heute für den herbst vorsorgen stimmen
sie heute für unseren gesetzentwurf
hätte
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
sepp müller
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren
viele von uns eint das ziel dass wir im
herbst diesen jahres keine überlastung
des gesundheitssystems haben und ich
appelliere insbesondere an diejenigen
die heute unentschlossen in diesem
parlament sitzen insbesondere aus der
ampel koalition sich unseren antrag
anzuschließen
bei dieser ist vorsorge der sie drei
punkte vor wir möchten ein impf register
haben um zu wissen wer ist denn
überhaupt in unserem land gekämpft
wir wollen mit diesem ins register die
menschen anschreiben und darüber
informieren welche möglichkeiten sie
haben sich impfen zu lassen und die
dritte möglichkeit zu schaffen dass wir
einen regelmäßigen bericht des
bundesgesundheitsministers hier im
deutschen parlament beraten und wenn
dieser bericht ergibt das eine
tödlichere variante kommt die
ansteckender ist dass wir dann natürlich
eine impfpflicht scharf schalten und das
ist vorsorge liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und bitte schließen sie sich
unserem antrag an
herr müller
gestatten sie eine frage oder zwischen
werden aus der fraktion die grünen ja an
stammen ja sie haben das wort verdammt
vielen dank herr kollege müller dass sie
die frage zu lassen ich würde sie gerne
tragen wollen ob ihnen bewusst ist dass
es in unserem land erforderlich ist dass
damit regeln gelten ein gesetz
beschlossen werden muss und es nicht
ausreicht einen antrag hier im parlament
zu beschließen der erste teil einer
frage und der zweite teil ist ihnen
bewusst dass die drei
wesensmerkmale ihres antrags die sie
beschreiben nämlich dass es eine
verbesserte datengrundlage einen
regelmäßigen bericht eine befassung des
bundestages mit einem mechanismus der
aktivierung weitere altersgruppen
gegenstand einer abstimmung eines
gesetzesentwurfes heute hier im
bundestages ist und wenn dem so ist ist
der dritte teil meiner frage was hindert
sie daran genau diese wesensmerkmale
ihres antrags bis hin zum alter von 60
jahren heute mit einer unterstützung
hier im bundestag den weg zu ebnen weil
das wesen der vorsorge uns im beispiel
und bild zu machen ja darin besteht dass
man vor sorgt und nicht handelt wenn der
schaden eingetreten ist also die
feuerwehrwache baut nicht wenn es brennt
sondern im vorfeld damit die feuerwehr
vorbereitet ist insofern warum treffen
sie heute nicht vorsorge für den herbst
mit einem gesetzesvorschlag der vorliegt
und regeln dafür sorgen
[Applaus]
danke herr damen für ihre frage denn sie
gibt nochmal möglichkeit auch die
unterschiede klar zu machen sie haben
nämlich nicht die wesentlichen
bestandteile entnommen sie haben sich
weiteren gesprächen die wir angeboten
haben verwehrt haben auf die tube
gedrückt haben auf die tube gedrückt und
diese abstimmung heute hier im deutschen
bundestag erzwungen und ich möchte ihnen
vor allem 2 ich möchte ihnen vor allem
die beiden das wäre schön wenn sie mir
die frage stellen und zumindest dann die
auch dabei zuhören könnten ich möchte in
den beiden großen unterschiede sagen sie
möchten jetzt in ihrem antrag der über
nacht von 18 auf 50 auf 60 verändert
wurde eine beratungspflicht einführen
sie möchten diejenigen verpflichten die
noch nicht geimpft sind sich beraten zu
lassen währenddessen ihre ampel
koalition den ländern die finanzierung
für die impfzentren ab mitte diesen
jahres streicht wollen sie dass
ungeimpfte beraten werden sollen wo
sollen denn die das machen wo sollen die
denn das machen
wo sollen die das machen dann kommt ihre
antwort was sie gerade zwischen gerufen
haben bei ärzten und apothekern das kann
man tun aber dann sind sie doch so
konsequenz und zahlen den pflege bonus
auch den medizinischen fachangestellten
die vor ort nämlich gerade und hans
heuser die krankenhäuser vor der
überlastung schützen punkt nur eins sie
wollen die beratungspflicht die wir
nicht fürchten weil sie nicht umsetzbar
ist das sagt ihn auch nicht nur die
gesetzliche krankenversicherung sondern
das sagen ihnen auch alle kommunalen
spitzenverbände sie ist nicht umsetzbar
punkt nummer zwei
sie möchten eine impfpflicht heute
beschließen ab 60 und im zweiten schritt
dann für die 18 bis 59 jährigen das
unterscheidet uns sehr stark weil wir
sagen eine impfpflicht ist zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt weder verhältnismäßig noch
geeignet noch angemessen und ich sage
ihnen auch warum
ich sage ihnen auch warum
wir sehen in der aktuellen situation auf
den intensivstationen tatsächlich keine
überlastung durch corona infizierte wir
sehen aber eine überlastung auf den
gesundheits im gesundheitssystem durch
corona infiziertes medizinisches
personal
deswegen wird selektive deswegen wäre
ein selektiver eingriffe verschoben und
dieses medizinische personal ist geimpft
sie sehen also ihre impfpflicht die sie
jetzt beschließen wollen dient nicht dem
schutz zur überlastung des
gesundheitssystems sondern wir brauchen
dafür einen geeigneten impfstoff den wir
dann einsetzen wenn eine tödliche
variante kommt und vor diesem
hintergrund halten wir an unserem
vorsorge antrag fest sehr geehrter
herr müller
weitermachen nehmen im anschluss
auch der später das kriegen wir hin es
gibt noch einen frage wunsch aus der
spd-fraktion von rolf mützenich sehr
gerne da musst du dich sie haben das
wort
vielen dank frau präsidentin oder der
kollege müller
vielleicht können sie verstehen warum
ich mich in diesem moment zu wort
gemeldet habe als sie hier behauptet
haben dass wir uns gesprächen die sie
uns bis zum schluss haben angeboten
verwerter ich möchte hier und ich hoffe
auch in mit ihrem einverständnis sie
können ja gleich darauf auch noch mal
antworten bezug nehmen dass wir mehrere
fach politische gespräche zwischen
einzelnen abgeordneten unter anderem mit
ihnen geführt haben und dass ich nach
dem 16
ministerpräsidentin und
ministerpräsident der bundesrepublik
deutschland uns zweimal gebeten in einem
beschluss der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
eine impfpflicht hier im deutschen
bundestag auf den weg zu bringen auch
das gespräch mit der union besucht habe
und auch versucht habe kriterien zu
finden die ein weg des gemeinsamen hier
im deutschen bundestag zu gehen ich wäre
ihnen dankbar wenn sie das zumindestens
heute hier in dieser debatte noch einmal
richtig stellen würden das bis zum
schluss dieser weg versucht worden ist
dass am ende als wir aber kenntnis
bekommen haben das was der erste
parlamentarische geschäftsführer
den mitgliedern seiner fraktion zur
kenntnis gegeben hat offensichtlich und
sie diese chance am ende verbauen
wollten was ich sehr bedaure
für mich
es ist ein sehr strenges bild welches
lieder zeichnen
es ist deswegen ein sehr schönes bild
und wir haben verschwiegenheit
vereinbart in den gesprächen aber eins
kann man eins kann man eins kann man
sagen und das kann der kollege das kann
der kollege wie sie nachher sicherlich
bestätigen unsere fraktion ich war mit
verhandlungsführer hat jedes mal darauf
hingewiesen dass unsere fraktionsgremien
darüber erst beraten und wir dann weiter
in das verfahren gehen was hat ihre
fraktion gemacht am montagvormittag
schickt ihr stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender 11 19 eine e mail
an alle abgeordnete und setzt uns vor
vollendete tatsachen so geht man nicht
miteinander um wenn man eine lösung des
problems richter punkt nummer 1 und
nummer 2 mützel nicht es ist ein sehr
verschobenes bild welches ihr zeichnen
wenn sie die 16 ministerpräsidenten
erwähnen und dann vergessen den halbsatz
zu sagen welche kritik die
ministerpräsidenten an der bereits von
uns mitgetragen sektoralen impfpflicht
und deren durchführung haben dass die
kommunikation zwischen
bundesregierung insbesondere des spd
bundesgesundheitsministers und der
ministerpräsidenten überhaupt nicht
klappt und die kirsche auf die sahne hat
karl lauterbach mit der rücknahme der
isolations zeiten gemacht kommunikatives
desaster
diese ampel ist in der pandemie politik
tätig
herr müller
sie können wieder einen schluck wasser
trinken ich frage sie ob sie noch eine
zwischenfrage zu lassen von frau ahadi
hatte frau präsidentin wir haben
ausreichend redezeit ich denke ich komme
zum schluss damit wir auch die argumente
abwägen
sie können aber gerne zwischen
interventionen machen kollegen aber
lassen sie uns die argumente aus dann
lasse ich ihre redezeit jetzt wieder
weiter laufen und fahren in der debatte
fort vielen dank frau präsidentin
und deswegen geringen wir auch heute
deswegen ringen wir auch heute in diesem
parlament um den richtigen weg
und wir haben viele wir haben viele auch
ausgewogene reden gehört ein paar lasse
ich mal außen vor
und darum möchte ich auch noch mal
ausdrücklich für unseren antrag werden
und vielleicht hätte die kollegin
hasselmann die frage gestellt die die
anderen kollegen gestellt haben was ist
das thema wenn sie später anfangen zu
impfen mit der ersten impfung wenn sie
später anfangen wollen zu impfen und
darauf möchte ich auch eine frage geben
gerade den unentschlossenen kollegen die
sich gerne unserem antrag anschließen
können
und kollegen denn selbstverständlich auf
weiß
karl lauterbach hat am zweiten januar
dieses jahres
in einer sonntagszeitung
und am 13 januar diesen jahres hier im
parlament dafür geworben dass die
erstimpfung gegen den tödlichen verlauf
schützt und somit gegen die belegung der
intensivbetten und meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren das ist auch die
antwort auf ihre frage und gerade für
die unentschlossenen wenn sie unserem
antrag folgen wir vorsorge leisten wir
dann wissen wenn es eine tödliche
variante gibt die impfpflicht nach
kohorten beschließen dann reicht die
erstimpfung dazu aus das
gesundheitssystem nicht zu überlasten
und dass es geeignet dass es angemessen
und das ist verhältnismäßig
und nun ist der fokus heute auf dieses
parlament gerichtet und viele möchten
natürlich
diese debatte abschließen heute sie
wollen eine entscheidung wissen sie
wollen vorankommen
es kann aber am ende sein dass unser
antrag keine mehrheit findet und wir
deswegen auch keine mehrheit hier im
parlament sehen um unserem guten
vorsorge mechanismus vorzustellen das
wird uns aber nicht davon abhalten liebe
kollegen sehr geehrter herr mützenich
dass wenn der rauch
verschwunden ist die türen auf sind und
das geht dann ab morgen gerne weiter und
wir für gespräche bereit stehen um uns
gegen die herbst welle zu schützen weil
das imwf register ist wichtig eine
dokumentation und ein anschreiben
derjenigen es wichtig die nicht geimpft
sind und ein vorsorge mechanismus dafür
zu treffen dass wenn eine tödliche
variante kommt wie auch dann eine
impfpflicht beschließen können vielen
dank
bevor ich den nächsten redner aufrufe
hat das wort zu einer kurzintervention
[Applaus]
vielen dank frau präsidentin
meine damen und herren die argumentation
die gerade der abgeordnete müller aus
der cdu/csu-fraktion
hier dem parlament da gebracht hat heißt
ja wie folgt heute
darf es keine entscheidung in der sache
für eine impfpflicht geben
weil man aus prinzip und aus kritik an
herrn lauterbach oder wein an das
verfahren sein buch kritisieren darf man
heute als abgeordnete nicht
selbstständig denken sondern
alle türen bei der cdu/csu wieder
aufmachen und weiter sprechen damit am
ende vielleicht eher märz die krone auf
hat als kompromiss
[Applaus]
yeah
wir haben eine schwerwiegende
entscheidung zu treffen eine wirklich
schwerwiegende entscheidung zu treffen
in der sache wegen
cdu/csu noch für bündnis 90 die grünen
noch für die ampel oder ein
gesundheitsminister
sobald für die menschen im land und für
eine voraus
aufhören ihnen der fraktion der
öffentlichkeit diese lägen dazu erzählt
wir wären nicht gesprächsbereit
und jetzt liegt ihre
verweigerungshaltung daran dass jung
montag um 11 uhr 11 eine nachricht
gekriegt habe seit vier monaten
reden wir über die einführung einer
internet
sie den präsidenten auf der wiesn in
nordrhein-westfalen der wald eine
landtagswahl vor sich hat
erwarten vom deutschen bundestag dass
wir im pflicht einführen und sie drücken
sich weg und die frage gesprächsangebote
meine damen und herren weil der hitze
nicht so auch geäußert habe ich kann
nicht dafür
ich kann mich dafür dass der
fraktionsvorsitzende der cdu csu
nicht in der lage ist eine termin mit
der
fraktionsvorsitzende von bündnis 90 die
grünen zu finden
was dabei
müller
ja die möglichkeit zu erwidern
bevor
sie haben recht wir haben heute eine
sehr sachlich orientierte debatte die
wir wirklich geringen wir ringen in der
sache um die richtige lösung
und deswegen sind wir uns sicherlich
darüber einig dass hier keine trennung
in diesem parlament ist zwischen
moralisierend auf der einen seite und in
der sache in der sache eine
unterschiedliche auffassung zu haben auf
der anderen seite ich gehe davon aus
dass trennt uns nicht sondern ich sehe
ja auch in ihrer fraktion dass es
unterschiedliche meinungen gibt zum
thema antrag behrens punkt nummer eins
punkt nummer zwei sie sprechen die vier
monate an vier monate
und sie erzeugen da und wollen damit ein
bild erzeugen dass unsere fraktion so
locker meinen antrag hier hinten
geworfen hat sie nicken dann muss ich
widersprechen es war unsere fraktion die
den bundeskanzler und dem
bundesgesundheitsminister vor
weihnachten einen fragenkatalog zukommen
lassen der nicht beantwortet wurde es
war unsere fraktion habe man hier
bezüglich der allgemeinen pflicht dann
eine kleine anfrage gestellt hat die
nicht zeitgerecht beantwortet wurde es
war unsere aktion die sich zuerst mit
expertinnen und experten zusammengesetzt
hat und dann über die allgemeine
impfpflicht im kompletten
fraktionsstärke debattiert hat und es
war unsere fraktion der es gelungen ist
als volkspartei diese meinung zu einen
in einen antrag vorzutragen und dafür
heute auch zu werben damit wir diesen
weg gehen des vorsorge mechanismus und
frau hasselmann ihnen steht es frei sich
uns anzuschließen es wäre der richtige
weg
nächster redner für die gruppe behrens
und janitschek und andere ist stefan
schwartze
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren ich
weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht aber ich
würde mehr über die sache und die
situation der menschen im land reden als
über das taktische hin und her und wer
wann mit wem hätte sprechen sollen
ich hätte heute morgen auch gerne eine
impfpflicht ab 18 beschlossen weil ich
sie für die beste vorsorge halte die wir
hätten treffen können
nur feststellen die hat leider keine
mehrheit
und darum werde ich heute umso
entschlossener für den jetzt vorgelegten
kompromiss einer impfpflicht ab 60 drei
punkte sind mir dabei ganz besonders
recht wichtig ich möchte jetzt noch die
bestmögliche vorsorge vor dem nächsten
winter treffen dabei ist impfen
unersetzbar und ganz besonders für die
älteren
lassen sie uns alles tun damit wir eine
überlastung im gesundheitssystem
vermeiden und die gibt es ich habe es
gerade noch in der letzten woche gehabt
dass bei mir vor ort im wahlkreis zwei
von drei krankenhäusern aus dem
regelbetrieb genommen worden weil das
personal erkrankt war und damit gibt es
eine ernsthafte situation für alle
menschen im kreis
wir
sollten solche situationen unbedingt
verhindern
und jetzt bitte ich sie einmal die
perspektive zu wechseln nicht hier als
abgeordneter sondern die perspektive von
patientinnen und patienten einzunehmen
viele menschen mussten seit der beginn
der pandemie
green benötigte behandelt bring
benötigte op verschieben
was bedeutet das für die menschen die
mussten mit weiter mit der krankheit
leben die mussten mit schmerzen leben
die mussten mit der großen ungewissheit
leben wann bekomme ich endlich meine op
was wird das ergebnis dieser op sein und
das hat spuren hinterlassen
und ich finde über diese menschen wird
viel zu wenig geredet und wir müssen
viel mehr in unseren diskussionen
stattfinden wir haben viele opfer aus
sich gemacht
wir können an den zahlen ablesen
dass viel weniger menschen zur
vorsorgeuntersuchung gegangen sind
selbst
krebspatienten sind nicht zur nachsorge
gegangen um zur kontrolluntersuchung
sommer haben aus angst vor ansteckung
aus angst davor das gesundheitssystem
weiter zu belasten auf diese wichtigen
termine verzichtet und ich denke auch
die müssen wir in den fokus nehmen
und ich habe mit vielen menschen geredet
die an den folgen der korona erkrankung
leiden die schwerwiegende folgen über
lange zeit ertragen müssen und auch die
möchte ich schützen das sind schwere
schicksale das kann ganze leben
zerstören und auch die müssen wir in den
fokus nehmen und darum bitte ich sie
an die menschen die die op s verschoben
haben denken sie an den menschen die
unter den langzeitfolgen der korona
infektion leiden und deshalb stimmen sie
unseren kompromissantrag zu vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner ist der abgeordnete
johannes huber
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin die jetzt
wechselt liebe mitbürger
verfassungsrechtlich muss nicht das vom
grundgesetz geschützte
selbstbestimmungsrecht begründet werden
sondern immer die einschränkung der
freiheit das selbstbestimmungsrecht
verbietet es den einzelnen zu seinem
eigenen schutz zur impfung zu
verpflichten es kommt also lediglich das
ziel des fremdschutz ascent frage die
geeignetheit jeglicher m pflicht es
dafür aber nicht gegeben weil die
verfügbaren probiert 19 impfstoffe keine
ausreichende immunität und damit keinen
ausreichenden fremdschutz erzeugen
menschen mit impfung sind bei einer
infektion nicht weniger anstrengend als
personen ohne impfung also kann die
impfung keine infektionsketten
unterbrechen die immer weniger
gefährliche omikron variante zeigt
aktuell laut zwei dänischen kroaten
studien zu mit mrt wochenbericht das
nach wenigen wochen die impfung keinen
positiven effekt mehr auf die
wahrscheinlichkeit einer infektion hat
sondern die wahrscheinlichkeit einer
infektion sogar erhöht die
erforderlichkeit vielleicht ist
ebenfalls zu verneinen frau schmidt
besonders sie angesprochen weil
spätestens mit dem auftreten der omicron
variante die zahl der erkrankungen mit
schwerem verlauf das niveau einer
normalen saisonalen grippe erreicht hat
die impfung ist doch nicht alternativlos
wie uns der heute sehr nervöse herr
lauterbach immer noch glauben lassen
möchte denn es stehen heute erfolgreiche
milder der mitte wie bereits verwendete
und zugelassene medikamente zur
verfügung es gibt auch keine
signifikante überlastung des
gesundheitswesens laut dass die wir ist
dass amerika betrug die mittlere
belastung der intensivbetten von
patienten mit kubik nur 9,5 prozent eine
impfpflicht das daher nicht
verhältnismäßig weil die verfügbaren
bedingt zugelassen cupid 19 impfstoffe
wieder fremd schützend noch sicher vor
risiken sind gemessen an der
gefährlichkeit und häufigen
nebenwirkungen die vom
paul-ehrlich-institut öffentlich
dokumentiert sind ein gesetz für eine
kopie 19 impfpflicht darf in der folge
nicht verabschiedet werden auch nicht
auf vorrat da ist für den schutz nicht
geeignet nicht erforderlich nicht
angemessen damit verfassungswidrig ist
schulpräsidentin ich komme zum schluss
mit einem vorschlag unsere gespaltene
gesellschaft aber wieder etwas mehr zu
versöhnen dazu muss aber die
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht wieder
aufgehoben werden und soldaten müssen
heute mehr denn je genauso behandelt
werden wie die mehrheit in diesem land
nämlich frei von jeglichem pflicht
vielen dank
[Applaus]
vielen dank liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich grüße sie herzlich
und da als nächstes das wort geben der
abgeordneten nina starb für die
kuschelbären zehn sekunden
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ja es stimmt wir treten in eine
neue phase der pandemie ein endlich
endlich wieder kindergeburtstag im
schwimmbad den abend mit freundinnen und
freunde die kneipe und ich gönne es von
herzen gegen der langsam wieder in diese
normalität zurück kommt und das dürfen
wir auch genießen aber wir dürfen
darüber nicht die vergessen für die
diese normalität noch meilenweit
entfernt ist
stellvertretend
stellvertretend dafür möchte ich heute
von einem mädchen hier aus berliner
berichten ich nenne sie jetzt mal laura
lara wird in wenigen tagen auf ihre
zwillingsschwester acht jahre alt sie
ist mit spina bifida also mit einem
offenen rücken auf die welt gekommen sie
hat entgegen alle ärztlichen voraussagen
doch laufen gelernt sie ist eine
kämpferin genauso ihre eltern und doch
ihre gesundheit ist weiterhin fragil und
wir wissen nicht was passiert wenn sie
jetzt corona bekommt für lager und ihre
geschwister und für alle anderen
schatten familien gilt kein
kindergeburtstag kein schwimmbad und die
eltern sitzen abends allein stadt mit
freundinnen und freunden in der kneipe
und das seit mehr als zwei jahren es ist
unsere verantwortung im blick zu haben
dass auch sarah und ihre familie das
recht auf freiheit gilt frau kollegen
laufen sie eine zwischenfrage aus der
fdp-fraktion
[Applaus]
kritische frau kollegin vielen dank dass
sie die zwischenfrage zu lassen
die frage ist ja wie ihr vorschlag
eigentlich administriert werden soll
also sie schlagen eine beratungspflicht
vor sie schlagen eine impfpflicht form
wie soll das eigentlich technisch und
praktisch umgesetzt werden ich frage das
deshalb weil der wahlkreis ja in berlin
ist und berlin ist ja dafür bekannt dass
es besonders
lange dauert wenn man
administrative dinge vor ort machen will
ein personalausweis anmelden will was
sich ummelden will sich anmelden will
also teilweise dauert das ja wochen und
monate hier in berlin wie wollen sie
dafür sorgen dass das tatsächlich in
berlin auch umgesetzt werden kann
die merkel lege vielen dank für diese
zwischen stage ich weiß nicht ob sie das
wissen ich war bevor ich in den
bundestag gekommen in berliner
landesvorsitzende der grünen ich durfte
in dieser funktion auf
koalitionsgespräche mit der fdp in
berlin führen das war leider nicht
erfolgreich ich muss aber sagen wir
haben eine sehr sehr gute zusammenarbeit
mit den linken in berlin deswegen ich
finde beide konstellationen sehr
konstruktiv und ich kann ihnen sagen wir
haben innerhalb der letzten fünf jahre
in der rot-rot-grünen koalition in
berlin massive fortschritte gemacht was
vorher die große koalition tut mir leid
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen unter
schwarz rot in berlin runter gerockt hat
ja sparen bis es quietscht
da haben wir wieder extrem viel aufbauen
können und ja wir sind noch nicht da wo
wir hinwollen aber wir haben wieder
erreicht und ich höre bei ihnen raus sie
wollen das als fdp auch im berliner
abgeordnetenhaus unterstützen das kann
ich nur befürworten herzlichen dank
dafür und ich bin mir sicher wenn wir
alle gemeinsam versuchen das gemeinsam
hin zu bekommen dann werden wir auch die
ämter entsprechend ausstatten können
diese beratungspflicht und dann die
impfpflicht wenn sie denn zieht auch für
die jüngeren gut gemeinsam umsetzen zu
können und ich freue mich auf ihre
unterstützung da war
kommt zurück zu meiner rede es ist
unsere verantwortung die familien im
blick zu haben auch für die gilt das
recht auf freiheit und deshalb ist es
gut dass wir heute über einen kompromiss
diskutierende ein weg eröffnet
vorbereitet in den herbst zu gehen und
damit besonders sie zu schützen die es
brauchen es ist kein geheimnis dass ich
mich eigentlich für eine impfpflicht ab
18 eingesetzt habe mit blick besonders
auf die gefährdet gefährdeten menschen
aber ich werde nun voller überzeugung
für diesen kompromiss weil dieser weg
einen entscheidenden beitrag leisten
kann das infektionsgeschehen zu
verringern und deshalb schaue ich
insbesondere richtung der ist der
cdu-fraktion warum weil dieser
kompromiss genau das beinhaltet was sie
fordern das hat frau pieper sehr genau
ausgeführt wird und deshalb bitte ich
sie inständig denken sie an kinder wie
lehrer denken sie an die kinder die alle
massive einschränkungen hinnehmen
mussten in den letzten zwei jahren
lassen sie das nicht noch mal zu im
herbst lassen sie bitte für diese
familien ihre partei spielchen beiseite
lassen sie uns zum wohle der menschen in
diesem land abstimmen ich bitte sie
inständig stimmen sie diesen kopf guten
kompromiss zu helfen sie das
infektionsgeschehen zu reduzieren und
geben sie den menschen die seit zwei
jahren isoliert sind endlich ihre
freiheit zurück vielen dank
[Applaus]
und nun erhält das wort dieter
janitschek für die gruppe behrens
janitschek und andere
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin der
heutige tag könnte eine sternstunde des
deutschen bundestages werden wenn wir
ernst nehmen was wir uns versprochen
haben dass diese wesentliche
entscheidung heute über die einführung
einer impfpflicht in deutschland eine
gewissensentscheidung jedes und jeder
einzelnen ist wir frei abgewählte wir
frei gewählte abgeordnete
tragen heute die verantwortung und wir
lassen uns dabei nicht leiten von
fraktionszwängen und parteitaktischen
erwägungen
und ja frei herr müller ich glaube ihnen
dass sie sich ernsthaft
auseinandergesetzt haben und ich zolle
ihnen respekt nicht solle auch herrn
kubicki respekt auch all denjenigen die
heute gegen eine impf weg stimmt aber
was ich ihnen nicht glaube ist dass ihre
100 97 abgeordnete alle die gleiche
position haben sie sich völlig
unterscheidet von den acht cdu
ministerpräsidenten geben sie die
abstimmung heute frei
nehmen sie ihre verantwortung wahr
diese pandemie hat uns allen viel
abverlangt und auch ich habe mich heute
schwergetan
diesem vorschlag zuzustimmen
doch nach langer intensiver debatte ist
heute der tag zu einer entscheidung zu
kommen oben bestmöglich auf den
kommenden herbst und winter vorbereitet
zu sein und ich glaube dass dieser
antrag der impfpflicht ab 60 jahren
deswegen gangbar ist weil er eben
verhältnismäßig ist er konzentriert sich
auch die hauptbetroffenen risikogruppen
und es ist nun mal so dass über 90
prozent der intensivpatienten über 60
sind und es sterben immer noch so viele
die aktuelle impfquote reicht nicht um
sicherzustellen dass es nicht zu einer
erneuten schweren belastung unseres
gesundheitssystems kommt
lassen sie mich zum schluss eine
persönliche note sagen ich habe in den
letzten zwei jahren nicht sehr oft zu
dem thema geäußert dass kinder und
jugendliche in der pandemie aus meiner
sicht zu stark eingeschränkt worden sind
ich fand das war falsch wie wir in der
summe vorgegangen waren und auch
deswegen will ich keinen winter mehr
leben in dem die mangelnde impfquote bei
den älteren dafür erhält weitreichende
einschränkungen bei kindern und
jugendlichen zu rechtfertigen bitte
stimmen sie deswegen für den kompromiss
geben sie sich einen ruck lassen sie uns
zusammen arbeiten in dieser wichtigen
frage bilder
[Applaus]
es folgt die kollegin heike behrens für
die gruppe behrens janacek und anderen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
jetzt gilt es farbe zu bekennen wer
tatsächlich vorsorgen will wer endlich
einiges das schaffen will ja wer sich
zutraut noch einmal mit einer wichtigen
kraftanstrengung für das bei impfen zu
werben mit einer engagierten beratungs
kampagne die impfquote auf das niveau zu
heben das uns vor die nächste welle
bringt der sollte heute dem gesetz zur
pandemievorsorge zustimmen
es war richtig die diskussion über eine
allgemeine impfpflicht ausführlich hier
im bundestag aber auch in der gesamten
gesellschaft zu führen auf die fach
expertise aus den verschiedensten
bereichen hören und in veranstaltungen
in gesprächen oder per mail mit vielen
vielen bürgerinnen und bürgern zu
diskutieren und
fraktionsübergreifend um den richtigen
weg zu bringen
und da bleibt es irritierend und
befremdlich dass ausgerechnet die
christdemokraten sich diesen politischen
prozess der konsensbildung entzogen
haben
versorge sie haben vorhin gesagt wir
reichen ihnen die hand zur versöhnung
wir haben gar nicht gestritten weil sie
sich der diskussion entzogen haben
sie wollen heute hier aus rehna
praktischen kalkül die abstimmung zum
scheitern bringen und das ist nicht in
ordnung denn der vorsorge will der muss
vorsorge und nicht erst dann reagieren
wenn die infektionswelle in sicht ist
und darum verabschieden sie sich endlich
von ihrer mogelpackung
mit dem vorliegenden gesetzentwurf haben
wir brücken gebaut eine brücke zwischen
zwei gesetzentwürfen eine brücke
zwischen vielen abgeordneten die
gesellschaftliche verantwortung
übernehmen wollen die vorsorge treffen
wollen um uns vor einem dritten pandemie
herz zu schützen auch für alle
glauben sie eine zwischenfrage aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion
vielen dank frau kollegin während sie
mich hat direkt angesprochen haben
obwohl dies im grunde nur fragen sie
erwecken ja hier wieder den eindruck als
seien wenig gesprächsbereit gewesen
konnte ich möchte diesen eindruck hier
auch nicht so stehen lassen da sie ja in
den gesprächen beziehungsweise in den
signalen man könnte ja noch mal drüber
sprechen nachdem wir das ja seit ende
letzten jahres angeboten haben wo das
immer belächelt worden ist dann kam
unser kompromissvorschlag dann ist
dieser auch mehr oder weniger belächelt
wurden und hat sie jetzt auf den letzten
metern mitbekommen haben dass sie keine
mehrheit für diese allgemeine
impfpflicht bekommen diese danach
geschenke in anführungsstrichen zu
machen und zu sagen na ja wir könnten ja
über einen in frick ist normal reden das
kommt dann
irgendwann das ist ja aus ihrer sicht
vielleicht ein gesprächsangebot wir
haben immer darauf hingewiesen dass wir
uns mal grundsätzlich zusammensetzen
müssen und dieser vorschlag den wir
gemacht haben der ist ja selbst von
vielen kolleginnen kollegen von ihnen
gut geheißen worden die sagen uns ja
selbst das ist ja gangbarer weg weil sie
ja selbst sich nicht so sicher sind also
von 18 auf 50 dann auf 60 sie haben
anfang der woche ein kompromiss
verkündet mit der gruppe 50 die post
renten gesagt haben das ist mit denen
gar nicht abgesprochen gewesen mit uns
auch nicht also ich will nur deshalb
noch mal darauf hinweisen dass auch ihr
argument was nicht immer bringen also
der im vorsorge mich mechanismus den wir
als union vorgeschlagen haben sei zu
spät ich will nur darauf hinweisen es
geht darum dass wir reagieren können und
der im focus sorge mechanismus heißt
gehalten momentan die impfzentren müssen
menschen in standby erhalten wir können
millionen von menschen haben in der
hochphase bewiesen innerhalb von tagen
impfen und deshalb meine frage sind sie
mit mir nicht auch der meinung dass es
darum geht vorsorge zu treffen was wir
sehr schnell tun können mit unserem
vorsorge mechanismus anstatt jetzt
pauschal in grundrechte einzugreifen in
dem wissen dass das überhaupt für den
herbst nichts bringen würde
also zum einen will ich einfach mit
dieser mehr noch mal aufräumen dass sie
gesprächsbereit gewesen wären es ist der
versuch unternommen worden auf ganz
unterschiedlichen ebenen zwischen den
fraktionen zwischen abgeordneten
kolleginnen und kollegen mit ihnen ganz
konstruktiv in den dialog zu kommen und
dieses war nicht möglich weil sie seit
monaten ausschließlich auf ihren antrag
verweisen da ja nicht mal ein
gesetzentwurf ist sie sind ja nicht mehr
als größte oppositionsfraktion in der
lage einen abend diesen gesetzentwurf
für das kurze leben was sie uns hier so
präsentieren wollen
und sie haben es ist völliger unsinn er
frei nein das ist völliger unsinn was
sie da sagen
der andere punkt ist sie haben selbst
eben in ihrem beitrag noch einmal gesagt
sie wollen reagieren wir reagieren seit
zwei jahren
situationsangepasst und versuchen die
infektionswellen so klein wie möglich zu
halten
reaktion alleine reicht nicht sondern
echte vorsorge ist gefragt und genau
dafür
und genau da wo heute ein gesetzentwurf
zur abstimmung der eingestuftes vorgehen
vorsieht und der vor allem für zwei
zentrale punkte ihres antrages mit
aufnimmt nämlich dass er wirklich in
schritten diese umsetzung macht dass er
die zielgruppe der 60-jährigen die
besonders gefährdet sind durch eine
infektion hier adressiert und vor allem
und da habe ich den eindruck sie haben
den gesetzentwurf nicht mal gelesen es
ist ein ganz klarer auftrag tatsächlich
das in frühester jetzt auf den weg zu
bringen das müssten sie eigentlich heute
unterstützen
und darum sage ich sie alle liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen heute noch
einmal ein für diesen kompromiss
zustimmen denn es ist nicht mehr zu
akzeptieren dass so viele menschen an
hunger sterben es darf nicht sein dass
wir noch einmal in einen lock down
müssen und es darf nicht mehr sein dass
tumorpatienten auf operationen warten
müssen dass patienten wegen
personalausfall durch corona nicht
aufgenommen werden
dass wir alle und unsere familien vor
allem unsere familien mit kindern oder
auch alte menschen darunter leiden und
auch und das will ich auch noch mal die
cdu/csu sagen und auf unserer wirtschaft
sind die pandemie lasten nicht weiter
zuzumuten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich hoffe wir noch einmal an sie
verlassen sie ihre parteipolitische
zwickmühle sorgen sie jetzt mit uns vor
stimmen sie für unseren gesetzentwurf
vielen dank
und als nächstes gilt das wort dr till
steffen für die gruppe während jantscher
und an
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
wir
entscheiden heute darüber wie der
nächste herbst aussehen wird wir
entscheiden heute darüber ob wir endlich
raus kommen aus dieser dauerschleife von
lock down und lockerungen das hat unser
land genug erlebt die leute haben die
schnauze voll davon und heute fällt hier
die entscheidung ob wir es schaffen da
rauszukommen und
wie entscheidet der deutsche bundestag
der deutsche bundestag entscheidet
dadurch dass er gesetze beschließt
meistens
gesetze die ihm die bundesregierung
vorschlägt
und manche finden das gut dass die
bundesregierung hier keinen vorschlag
gemacht habe andere finden das blöd aber
es ist so wie es ist und unsere
verfassung sieht nicht vor dass man nur
gesetze beschliessen kann wenn die
bundesregierung einen vorschlag macht
sondern
jede fraktion jede gruppe kann
vorschläge für gesetze machen und das
haben wir gemacht wir haben diskutiert
mit kollegen der linken mit kollegen der
fdp mit kollegen der grünen und der spd
wir waren gesprächsbereit haben jetzt
erörtert und was nicht von ihnen vor
kein gesetz eine besinnung auf satz
liegt vor das lied vor der abgeordnete
erlauben sie eine zwischenfrage aus der
asd fraktion ein und wir haben uns
angeschaut ist ja nicht gesagt dass das
uninteressant ist da stehen interessante
punkte drin wir haben wir ein gearbeitet
das ist deutlich gemacht worden dass in
frage kommt weil sie es gefordert und
wir es eingearbeitet haben weil wir die
arbeit gemacht haben daraus eine
gesetzliche formulierung zu machen wir
haben das gemacht
wir wollen die besten ideen
zusammenführt eben diesem gesetz weil
wir die besten ideen brauchen um die
pandemie zu bekämpfen und das ist dass
herr frei was sie mit allen mitteln
bekämpfen wollen ich finde das traurig
und dass sie diesen brief schreiben
müssen zeigt ja auch was für ein druck
in ihrer fraktion ist ich möchte dass
wir heute entscheiden ein anderer herbst
ein anderer winter und ein weg raus aus
der pandemie vielen dank
vielen dank
für eine kurzintervention erhält das
wort der abgeordnete hilfe von der afg
fraktion
vielen dank frau präsidentin dass sich
die kurzintervention zu lassen
sie wollen heute entscheiden
dass sich jemand impfen lassen muss und
dafür das zeigen die statistiken auch
vom paul-ehrlich-institut
unter umständen
stirbt
und es gibt ein
bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil
wo ist sie werden sich wahrscheinlich
daran erinnern an das
luftsicherheitsgesetz
da hat das bundesverfassungsgerichts
folgendes gesagt und zwar am 15 februar
artikel 1 ich lese ich zitiere mit ihrer
genehmigung artikel 1 absatz 1
grundgesetz schützt den einzelnen
menschen nicht nur vor erniedrigung
brandmarkung verfolgung ächtung und
ähnlichen handlungen durch dritte oder
durch den staat selbst ausgehend von der
vorstellung des grundgesetz gebers dass
es zum wesen des menschen gehört in
freiheit sich selbst bestimmen und sich
frei entfalten und das der einzige
verlangen kann in der gemeinschaft
grundsätzlich als gleichberechtigtes
glied mit eigenwert anerkannt zu werden
schließt die verpflichtung zur achtung
und zum schutz der mensch würde vielmehr
generell aus den menschen zum bloßen
objekt des staates zu machen schlechthin
verboten ist damit jede behandlung des
menschen durch die öffentliche gewalt
die dessen subjekt qualität seinen
status als rechts weg grundsätzlich
infrage gestellt indem sie die achtung
des wertes vermissen lässt der jedem
menschen um seiner selbst willen kraft
seiner person science zukommt jemanden
der gesetz zu ermächtigen leben
gegeneinander aufzuwiegen also menschen
leben zu opfern um andere menschenleben
zu schützen schließt das
bundesverfassungsgericht somit aus
dieses gesetz was sie hier beschließen
wollen ist also ein nicht nur im
höchsten maße menschenfeindlich sondern
offensichtlich auch verfassungswidrig
der abgeordnete wollen sie antworten
kollege ihre
verdrehungen falschbehauptungen
werden durch wiederholung nicht besser
und als letzter redner in dieser debatte
erhält jetzt das wort dirk wiese für die
gruppe behrens janitschek und andere
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen wir treffen
einer langen intensiven debatte jetzt
hier und heute im deutschen bundestag
die entscheidung darüber ob diese
pandemie für uns im kommenden herbst und
winter beherrschbar ist ob wir wenn wir
heute eine negative entscheidung treffen
wieder darüber nachdenken müssen wieder
freiheits einschränkungen auf den weg zu
bringen wieder schließungen der
gastronomie auf den weg zu bringen
wieder einschränkungen für kinder und
jugendliche auf den weg zu bringen oder
ob wir hier die verantwortungsvolle
entscheidung heute treffen vorzusorgen
richtig vorzusorgen dass die pandemie
für uns beherrschbar ist und das ist die
entscheidung die jetzt gleich hier und
heute hier getroffen werden
und als größte gruppe haben wir uns
dafür entschieden verantwortung zu
übernehmen wir haben erkannt dass die
mehrheit für eine allgemeine impfpflicht
ab 18 ich da ist wir haben aber erkannt
dass wenn wir die anträge und
gesetzentwürfe zusammenlegen ist
eigentlich eine mehrheit für eine
impfpflicht im deutschen bundestag gibt
diese verantwortung haben wir angenommen
wir haben gespräche angeboten und vieles
ausdrücklich sagen ich bin der gruppe
ullmann dankbar dass wir zusammen
gefunden haben gemeinsam uns auf einen
gesetzentwurf verständigt der genau dazu
führen soll die pandemie beherrschbar zu
machen und da haben wir als stärkste
gruppe gemeinsam verantwortung
übernommen das auch gut so gewesen
und ich will das auch ausdrücklich
formulieren ja wir haben auch immer
wieder mit kolleginnen und kollegen der
cdu csu bundestagsfraktion gesprochen
lieber sepp müller wir haben auch in der
vergangenen woche am mittwoch gemeinsam
zusammen gesessen auch mit dem kollegen
stefan müller und haben in gesprächen
ausgelotet ob es möglich ist
zusammenzukommen und ich muss sagen dass
die csu das sei mir gestattet da sehr
viel konstruktiver in dieser runde
gewesen ist uns sehr viel näher sich den
kompromiss annehmen konnte als es die
union gewesen ist und wir haben auch
sehr deutlich gemacht dass aus unserer
sicht es möglich ist zusammenzufinden
aber gespräche sind etwas anderes als
konkrete verhandlungen ich muss das auch
sehr deutlich sagen nachdem friedrich
merz am samstagmorgen einen tweet
abgesetzt hat waren die gesprächskanäle
ruhig und es hat sich keiner mehr
gemeldet und es hat sich keiner mehr zu
ernsthaften verhandlungen von ihrer
seite bereit erklärt und das bedauere
ich sehr und wird der verantwortung
nicht gerecht und das muss ich auch sehr
deutlich sagen
jeder friedrich merz gesagt dass auch
sehr deutlich im sauerland sagen wir
beide ja dass franz müntefering im
zweifel recht opposition ist mist aber
opposition entbindet nicht von
staatspolitischer verantwortung und ich
sage das auch sehr deutlich
ich sage das sehr deutlich
man kann nicht hier im deutschen
bundestag heute sagen ich verweigere
mich staatspolitischer verantwortung
aber morgen stehe ich für gespräche
wieder bereit das ist unverantwortlich
und das ist nicht seriös vielen dank
vielen dank
ja soweit die debatte erst einmal teil
eins des heutigen tages 23 redner jede
menge zwischen fragen zu den vier
anträgen für die alle geworben haben die
vier anträge eben einerseits aus der
ampel koalition für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht ab 60 die union hat ihren
antrag noch einmal vorgestellt darum
geworben
ein im register aufzubauen und auch die
anderen gruppierungen die eine
impfpflicht allgemein ablehnen haben
ihre gründe noch mal vorgestellt das ist
hoch hergegangen sehr emotional es hat
sogar rügen gegeben der
bundestagspräsident hingegen abgeordnete
es wurde diskutiert ob es so einen
gesprächsbereitschaft gegeben habe ja
oder nein ob eine impfpflicht nun
vorsorge sei oder bevormundung und ob es
heute nun wirklich zu einer sternstunde
des parlamentarismus kommt nämlich eine
abstimmung eine abstimmung jetzt wollen
wir noch mal reinhören herr merz spricht
noch mal und erwidert da können wir mal
schnell rein hören
wir in unserer bundestagsfraktion einer
meinung was dieses thema impfpflicht
betrifft und deswegen gibt es von uns
anders als von allen anderen
bundestagsfraktionen hier einen
gemeinsamen antrag die zweite runde und
ist
wir sind hier von vielen rednern und ich
persönlich sehr hart kritisiert worden
für unsere haltung
naja ich wir akzeptieren das ist völlig
in ordnung aber dadurch doch einmal mir
den hinweis erlauben dass die tatsache
dass sie sich überhaupt so intensiv mit
uns beschäftigen müssen ihre ursache
allein darin hat dass diese fraktion
hier
überhaupt keine zustimmung zu einer
impfpflicht im deutschen bundestag
erwägt überhaupt kein ich nicht gehen
und deswegen ist meine dritte bemerkung
deswegen ist meine dritte bemerkung wenn
sie es wirklich ernst meinen mit einem
kompromiss dann manipulieren sie nicht
die reihenfolge der abstimmungen in der
wir jetzt vorgehen
wenn das der entscheidende das ist der
entscheidende test ob sie es ernst
meinen mit einem kompromiss der
weitergehende antrag ist ihre unser
antrag ist ein weniger weit gehende
antrag und diesen antrag können wir dann
gemeinsam beschließen und auf den weg
bringen mit einem gesetz im deutschen
bundestag aber nicht so wie sie es
machen um offensichtlich hier davon
abzulenken dass sie in ihrer eigenen
regierung keine mehrheit haben für das
was auf dieser fraktion kommt
ich schließe die aussprache schließe die
aussprache gesagt die bundestrainer
bundestagspräsidentin und damit ist die
debatte nun wirklich abgeschlossen aber
es war glaube ich ganz gut dass wir
jetzt am ende friedrich merz noch mal
gehört haben denn er hat damit auch noch
mal einen ganz ganz wichtigen punkt
gegeben es gibt viele streitereien die
es jetzt gegeben hat wer mit wem
gesprochen hat man nicht es wurden die
kalender quasi zitiert ich habe doch
angeboten wir können über einen
kompromiss sprechen sie haben aber den
termin nicht angenommen et cetera die
argumente sind ausgetauscht worden und
das entscheidende hat märz angedeutet es
gibt jetzt auch streit darüber in
welcher reihenfolge
abgestimmt wird über die vier vorschläge
die im raum sind er hat das wort
manipulation benutzt warum weil die
union folgenden trick wie sie es nennt
winkelzug war auch schon ein wort was
gefallen ist von der seite der ampel
koalition befürchtet sollte es nämlich
so sein dass der vorschlag der ampel
koalition ganz zum schluss als vierter
vorschlag erst kommt könnte das der
versuch der trick sein der wenn der
vorschlag der union abgelehnt wird das
dann vielleicht doch noch einige
abgeordnete der union dann dem vorschlag
der ampel koalition zustimmen also es
wird mit allen karten gespielt
vielleicht hören wir noch einmal auch
ganz schnell rein was thorsten frei von
der union erzählt
ist es so dass sie versuchen mit einer
nicht angemessenen reihenfolge der
abstimmungen des verfahren zu
torpedieren das akzeptieren wir nicht
das ist ein deutlicher beweis dafür dass
sie der überzeugungskraft ihrer eigenen
vorlagen misstrauen das ist
rechtsmissbräuchlich und deswegen lehnen
wir das ab worum geht es im kern
worum geht es im kern
wir haben eine lange parlamentarische
tradition dass immer zunächst über den
weitestgehenden antrag abgestimmt wird
so machen dass tausende von gemeinderäte
bei uns in deutschland so machen dass 16
länderparlamente der bundesrat macht es
so der hat es sogar in seiner
geschäftsordnung im paragrafen 30 absatz
2 normiert und so macht es der deutsche
bundestag seit jahrzehnten
es gibt praktisch keine ausnahmen davon
wenn ich eine finden würde dann wäre es
vielleicht im jahr 2009 als es um die
gesetzlichen regelungen für die
patientenverfügung gehen und dort ging
es darum dass man im grunde genommen
nicht exakt sagen konnte welches denn
der weitergehende antrag ist hier ist es
aber vollkommen klar fluchtpunkt ist die
realität der gesetzlichen status quo und
wer am weitesten vom gesetzlichen status
quo abweicht der hat den weitestgehenden
antrag und über den muss als erstes
abgestimmt werden liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
diese bundesregierung ist der auffassung
dass wir keine masken pflicht mehr
brauchen diese bundesregierung war
wenigstens für einige stunden der
auffassung dass wir keine quarantäne für
infizierte mehr brauchen diese
bundesregierung und diese diese
fraktionen hier im parlament wollen uns
aber weiß sagen dass eine impfpflicht
nicht der weitesgehend der antrag ist
und jedenfalls eine klare eingriffe in
die grundrechte das nimmt ihnen doch
kein mensch im land ab das ist einfach
nicht schlüssig und deswegen bitte ich
sie hier richtig abzustimmen ich will
auf eines hin weisen die politische
reise treffen aber dazu geschäfts nicht
zu den inhalten das will ich gerne
machen frau präsidentin die güte der
parlamentarischen demokratie zeigt sich
nicht darin dass am ende die mehrheit
entscheidet das ist selbstverständlich
sie zeigt sich darin dass die mehrheit
auch schranken akzeptiert schranken die
auch her gebrachtes recht hier im
parlament sind und darauf müssen sich
abgeordnete auch verlassen können und
darum geht es tauschen sie nicht aus
billigem machtpolitischem kalkül
politische kultur in diesem haus ein und
ein letztes will ich sagen dann komme
ich zu
dass es am schluss haben wir haben bei
dieser frage eine starke polarisierung
hier bei uns im land es geht auch darum
das zu überwinden und mit der von ihnen
vorgeschlagenen hatten abstimmungs
reihenfolge die letztlich nur zum ziel
hat den eigenen antrag zum erfolg zu
bringen dem wirken auch ein makel an
heften sollten sie sollte es ihnen
gelingen hier eine mehrheit zu gewinnen
das wird die akzeptanz nicht erst wenn
die sicherheit nicht fördern und es wird
nicht dazu führen dass treten in unserem
land zugeschüttet werden deswegen bitte
ich um zustimmung für unseren antrag
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das ist
eine wichtige debatte die müssen wir
auch ordentlich führen aber man sollte
bei einer geschäftsordnungsdebatte nicht
erst in der überziehung der zeit dann
auch auf die geschäftsordnung eingehen
da möchte ich noch mal eindringlich
darauf plädieren jetzt erhält das wort
hat ja mast spd
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren lieber
thorsten frei wer mit anderen auch mit
dem finger zeigt da zeigen immer vier
zurück das sollte man sich bewusst
machen wenn man solche reden hält um was
geht es hier eigentlich
es geht hier um eine abstimmung
reihenfolge es geht hier darum dass die
geschäftsordnung des deutschen
bundestags sich nicht zu einer
abstimmung reihenfolge im deutschen
bundestag äußert und nix festlegt und es
geht darum dass die verwaltung des
deutschen bundestags alle fraktionen
anheim gestellt hat zwei
unterschiedliche wege abzustimmen
nämlich den weg die gesetzentwürfe
zuerst und dann die anträge nach
reichweite oder umgekehrt die anträge
und dann die gesetzentwürfe nach
reichweite und das ist das worum es geht
es geht nicht um mehr und nicht um
weniger bei dieser entscheidung und es
ist völlig normal dass in der demokratie
wenn es zwei verschiedene wege gibt man
abstimmt und die mehrheit am ende
entscheidet das ist das normalste von
der welt und 2009 bei der
patientenverfügung hat mein kollege ja
gerade gesagt gab es das auch schon mal
also es ist nicht so dass es nicht
historische vorbilder auch gäbe herr
merz sie dürften sich noch daran
erinnern sie waren damals gerade noch
abgeordneter herr frey war noch kein
abgeordneter
aber was sie hier aufhören ist einfach
großes tamtam und sie haben die worte
noch einmal benutzt manipulation tricks
machtkalkül das in die finger die auf
sie zeigen dieser stelle das ist zwar
rechtlich warum demokratie parlament und
das erweist dass auch entschieden zurück
wie soll man jetzt diese anträge wie
kann man diese anträge abstimmen könnt
sie anhand der anzahl der unterschriften
abstimmen in der reihenfolge dann würden
wir kubicki zuerst afd dann unionen dann
den gesetzentwurf abstimmen wir können
abstimmen nach der reihenfolge was
schafft eigentlich für die bürgerinnen
und bürger klarheit weil die bürgerinnen
und bürger die uns heute zu hören die
wollen doch dass wir eine entscheidung
treffen in diesem aus und sie wissen
woran sie sind weiter endlich als er
heuer sind es werde nicht als letztes
ausstellung weil nur ein gesetz gibt
diese sicherheit am ende des tages es
geht um klarheit klarheit die die
bürgerinnen und bürger verdient haben
die zwei jahre mit uns durch diese
pandemie gegangen sind und dieser
stimmte man sieht ganz klar vor den wir
haben die reihenfolge der tam tam partei
cdu csu dass es die erste reihenfolge
man kann die reihenfolge zu wählen das
ist in der geschäftsordnung möglich und
alle alle alle die meine argumente hier
nicht überzeugt haben ich weiß es gibt
welche davon im deutschen bundestag sie
können wenn sie nicht jetzt cdu
steigbügel heiter sein wollen für dieses
spektakel das sie hier veranstalten sich
auch in das vorwissen auf steht man sie
für reihenfolge 2 bei dieser abstimmung
der minister hält das vor doktor irene
mihalic für bündnis 90 die grünen
vielleicht beruhigen wir uns jetzt alle
erst mal wieder
die gemüter sind erhitzt sehr geehrte
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen ich finde auch jetzt diese
geschäftsordnungsdebatte und auch die
inhaltliche debatte zeigt uns allen ja
sehr deutlich für emotionalisiert diese
angelegenheit hier im deutschen
bundestag behandelt wird und ist es auch
wichtig dass wir hier wirklich eine
verantwortungsbewusste entscheidung
treffen denn der situation in der wir
uns in der pandemie bekämpfung und in
der wir uns hier mit unserem land
befinden und in dieser situation herr
freiherr märz haben sie sich dafür
entschieden mit uns über die abstimmungs
reihenfolge diskutieren zu wollen und
uns und uns tricksereien und rechts
missbräuchliches handeln vorzuwerfen
dabei sind sie es doch dabei sind sie es
doch die mit allen mitteln versuchen zu
verhindern dass ihre abgeordneten hier
eine entscheidung treffen die sie hören
dass ihr bestes und die wirklich
angemessen wäre in der sache sie
versuchen wir mit allen mitteln zu
verhindern dass ihre abgeordneten hier
eine verantwortungsbewusste entscheidung
treffen indem sie hier so eine
geschäftsordnungsdebatte vom zaun
brechen aber nicht wir sind
nicht wir sind es die ihre abgeordneten
daran hindern hier eine entscheidung in
der sache verantwortungsbewusst zu
treffen sondern sie sind ist sie setzen
ihre leute unter druck sie sagen sie
sollen einem impuls widerstehen falls
ihr antrag keine mehrheit bekommt
anderen vorlagen zuzustimmen meine damen
und herren was ist das für ein
demokratieverständnis dass es um
parlamentarisch und das ist auch er hat
auch nichts mit verantwortungsbewusster
pandemie politik zu tun und auf ihren
wunsch ihr diskutieren wir jetzt über
die abstimmungs reihenfolge um meine
kollegin katja mast hat ihnen gerade
noch einmal erklärt welche varianten
hier zur abstimmung stehen und auch wie
diese aber abstimmungsvarianten auf den
stimmzettel gelangt sind es handelt sich
dabei um vorschläge die die
bundestagsverwaltung uns unterbreitet
hat die alle fraktionen bekommen haben
die auch die antrags initiativen die
gruppen bekommen haben und zwischen
denen man jetzt entscheiden kann das ist
demokratisch das ist transparent das
sind sachgerecht sie empfehlen ihrer
fraktion die erste variante wir
empfehlen unserer fraktion für
abstimmungsvarianten zwei zustimmen uns
in dieser situation tricksereien
vorzuwerfen ist absurd meine download
und lassen sie mich zum schluss noch
sagen und lassen sie mich zum schluss
noch sagen wenn wir jetzt endlich per
stimmzettel verfahren über die
abstimmungs reihenfolge entschieden
haben dann geht es hier wirklich um was
dann geht es hier wirklich darum eine
sachgerechte entscheidung mit blick auf
den weiteren verlauf unserer pandemie zu
treffen und lassen sie mich diese
bemerkung noch machen herr frey artikel
38 des grundgesetzes gilt auch für die
fraktionen der cdu/csu an ganz platzen
[Applaus]
für die fdp fraktion erhält nun das wort
johannes vogel
liebe frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen wir haben jetzt hier eben
vom eigentlich von mir sehr geschätzten
kollegen thorsten frei indem im plenum
des deutschen bundestags wieder etwas
erlebt was wir die letzten tage schon
erleben dürften da haben sie ganz heftig
in die rhetorische trickkiste gegriffen
und parlamentarisch eine manipulation
sie haben sich sogar eben dazu
verstiegen ist sei rechtsmissbräuchlich
dass hier über die abstimmungs
reihenfolge abgestimmt wird lieber
kollege frei über kollege frei das
beschädigt die politische kultur hier
bei uns im parlament verfügt ganz jahr
fragen
es ist eben in der sache nicht so
eindeutig wie war es denn damals bei den
gruppen antragsverfahren oder das
bonn-berlin-gesetz wie ist es hier der
afg antrag übrigens der ändert auch ganz
eindeutig die rechtslage in deutschland
um ihr argument mal ad absurdum zu
führen also die abstimmungs reihenfolge
ist einfach nicht so ganz eindeutig und
wir haben im deutschen bundestag eine
ganz klare regelung bei zahllosen
gruppen verfahren nämlich wenn es kein
einvernehmen über die abstimmungs
reihenfolge gibt dann wird über die
abstimmungs reihenfolge abgestimmt so
einfach herr kollege frei so einfach ist
es
und
es wurde ja schon gesagt 2009 hatten wir
genau das zur patientenverfügung da war
ihr fraktionsvorsitzender noch im
deutschen bundestag da gab es keine
einigkeit danach wurde über die
abstimmungs reihenfolge abgestimmt
irgendein protest von friedrich merz
irgendein theater wie wir sie heute
erleben irgendein protest der union ist
im protokoll nicht vermerkt sie prügeln
im klassenzimmer rummachen aber nicht
mal ihre hausaufgaben liebe kolleginnen
kollegen von der union und das ist der
sache unangemessen nicht unangemessen
ich verstehe schon worum es ihm geht sie
wollen gerne dass von den anträgen die
sich irgendwie etwas mehr in richtung
impfpflicht vorstellen können ihre als
letztes abgestimmt wird weil sie hoffen
dass diejenigen die irgendwas machen
wollen dann sich hinter ihrem antrag
sammeln das ist okay das dürfen sie so
wollen ich sage ihnen aber wie meine
persönliche meinung ist ich glaube bei
einer grundrechtssensiblen frage wie bei
einer impfpflicht da geht es nicht darum
irgend was zu beschließen sondern da
muss jeder einzelne vorlage eine aktive
mehrheit der kolleginnen und kollegen
hier im deutschen bundestag bekommen und
ich sage ihnen auch noch was ich
persönlich
stimme deshalb gleich für abstimmungs
reihenfolge zu 2 weil die genau das
sicherstellt und dann gibt es entweder
für eines der konzepte hier eine
mehrheit oder es gibt sie eben nicht was
auch ein legitimes ergebnis dieser
debatte wer liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ihn geht es nur darum dass sie
irgendwie sich mit ihrem antrag
durchsetzen und das ist schäbig liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
das ist schäbig und leider reibt sich
dass 1 mein letzter gedanke in ihrem
gesamten umgang mit diesen gruppen
antragsverfahren von anfang an und bis
zur letzten minute haben sie das gruppen
antragsverfahren torpediert das ist eine
der eines der verfahren die unserem
parlamentarismus mit ausmachen bei
medizin ethischen fragen da gab es oft
sternstunden des parlaments und sie
machen gerade noch per schreiben an ihre
fraktionskollegen sie machen aus einer
medizin ethischen frage eine
parteipolitische in meiner fraktion gibt
es das nicht liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der union und deshalb
kommen sie bitte zum schluss fonds zum
schluss professionell müssen ist die
lage ganz einfach es gab keine einigkeit
über die abstimmungs reihenfolge wir
stimmen ab über die abstimmungs
reihenfolge so machen wir das in unserer
demokratie wir nennen das
parlamentarismus und danach entscheiden
wir klug in der sache vielen dank
das wort erhält der abgeordnete martin
sichert für die afg fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die geschäftsordnung und die
parlamentarischen gepflogenheiten sind
grundlagen der demokratie und sie sorgen
dafür dass gesetze nicht schon an
formalen gründen scheitert hier hat man
den eindruck dass selbst die
antragsteller dämpfe ich diese nicht
wollen denn sie stoßen das tor weit auf
für eine klage vor dem
verfassungsgericht sowohl durch das
vorgehen heute als auch durch das
prozedere gestern im ausschuss dass der
kompromiss dämmpflicht ab 18 und der
impfung ab 15 aber 50 die impfpflicht ab
60 sein soll dass es wirklich bizarre
aber noch ist das im
gesundheitsausschuss gestern früh nicht
mal zehn minuten nachdem er schriftlich
vorgelegt wurde über einen 25-seitigen
gesetzesentwurf abgestimmt wurde mittags
als der tagesordnungspunkt zukünftig
bereits drei stunden beendet war hieß es
plötzlich dass zwei stunden später ein
weiterer änderungsantrag vom
gesundheitsministerium beschlossen
werden müsste dieser änderungsantrag
wäre notwendig weil der in der früh
beschlossene zu viele rechtliche mängel
hat er mit zu heißer nadel ist das hier
alles gestrickt
so bekamen wir dann so bekamen wir dann
im gesundheitsausschuss um 13 uhr 54 per
mail und um 14 uhr fünf schriftlich
einen nun 31 seitigen gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt trotz unseres protestes wurde
darüber binnen nicht mal zehn minuten
abgestimmt und um 14 15 war die sitzung
bereits beendet das meine damen und
herren ist kein parlamentarismus das ist
eine farce
kein mensch kann 31 seiten voller
gesetzesänderungen binnen so kurzer zeit
in all ihren auswirkungen erfassen sie
haben mit der mehrheit der
ampelkoalition mal eben den
parlamentarismus ausgeben und wollen es
jetzt im plenum auch noch machen
sie wollen nicht den weitestgehenden
antrag zuerst beraten von diesem über
jahrzehnte in allen parlamenten parteien
und vereinen gelebten verfahren wollen
sie abweichen weil sie glauben dass das
die einzige möglichkeit ist wie sie eine
irgendwie geartete impfpflicht
durchbekommen dabei ist jetzt viel ein
weiterer schlag gegen die demokratie
denn jeder einzelne hier im bundestag
vertretene partei hatte im wahlkampf
versprochen dass es keine impfpflicht
geben wird hören sie auf die demokratie
und den parlamentarismus zu beschädigen
gerade aufgrund der massiven
grundrechtseingriff um die es hier geht
und der hohen bedeutung ist es wichtig
dass die geschäftsordnung und die
parlamentarischen gepflogenheiten
eingehalten werden daher lassen sie uns
wie immer den weitestgehenden antrag
nämlich die impfpflicht zuerst abstimmen
zum schluss noch 1 dass der
bundeskanzler in dieser zeit die
außenministerin vom nato-treffen
abberuft und der bundesregierung
offensichtlich die einschränkung der
grundrechte der eigenen bevölkerung
wichtiger ist als der frieden in der
ukraine das ist wirklich entlarvend
schluss mit dieser unwürdigen fas lang
lebe rechtsstaatlichkeit und demokratie
leben wir wieder das verfahren so wie
wir es immer getan haben vielen dank
[Applaus]
und es folgt für die fraktion die linke
der abgeordnete jan korte
eine frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren zunächst
kollegin katja mast findet schon relativ
bemerkenswert als spd-fraktion anderen
fraktionen zum beispiel meiner
vorzuwerfen
steigbügelhalter der cdu/csu zu sein was
haben sie die letzten 20 jahre
eigentlich gemacht waren ja wo sie
unterkommen wird die rother cdu/csu
peter
sodann möchte zum zweiten hier an merkel
zu dem verfahren also auch ich halte die
cdu csu fraktion jetzt nicht in jeder
hinsicht für eine seriöse
oppositionsfraktion aber was ja was aber
nun nicht gehen und das ist absolut
deswegen wollen wir gucken wer hat hier
ein demokratie problem dass sie eine
oppositionsfraktion vorwerfen ihre
oppositionsarbeit zu machen das ist nur
denk ich geradezu lächerlich und potenz
um das auch in einer zeit zu sagen dass
ihr gutes der
aberwitzig dieser argumentation und zum
dritten möchte ich anmerken die maler
johannes vogel also alle machen hier in
diesem hause parteipolitik außer die
parteien der ampel da ist geradezu
lächerlich so etwas zu behaupten damit
sollen
das ist doch quatsch
also ich möchte zunächst um verfahren zu
erstellen wir wären jetzt nicht in
dieser wie soll ich sagen etwas
aufgeladenen situationen hier in diesem
hohen hause wenn die letzte
bundesregierung und die jetzige
bundesregierung vernünftige politik
gemacht hat und das land ins chaos
gestoßen hätte das ist ja mal die
sachlage deswegen müssen wir das hier
diskutieren so und dann will ich zum
zweiten sagen also zu glauben es gibt
keine überlastung des gesundheitssystems
ich weiß nicht was mit ihnen los ist da
müssen wir mit den pflegerinnen und
pfleger und reden und im übrigen hatten
wir die über lasst uns auch schon froh
um das auch mal in jeder klarheit hier
zu sagen nun sind wir bei der
geschäftsordnung ich ganz für meine
fraktion die linke sagen dass wir uns
also anträge angucken und grundsätzlich
immer nachfragen entscheiden diese und
ihr verhalten werden ja das ist so das
ist ja auch seriös baku was da drinsteht
was der vorschlag ist und dann gucken
wir bessern sinnvollsten nach unserer
meinung ist und das unterscheidet uns ja
auch zu ihrer corona politik lieber
kollege laut aber man kann ein guter
arzt sein aber das heißt nicht dass wir
ein guter gesundheitsminister ist
deswegen gucken wir uns das hier an und
1 wissen sie ganz genau und deswegen
ständig sollten wir hier auch sie von
der ampel mal ehrlich sein ganz ehrlich
sein es ist gelebtes erfahren in jedem
ortsverein auch der sozialdemokratischen
partei meiner partei bei einer parteien
dass in jedem ortsverein der
weitestgehende antrag zunächst
abgestimmte darf dass die gefragt sind
sie doch nicht so als ob das irgendwie
anders
tun sie doch nicht einfach so das ist
die übliche praxis und wenn man das
jetzt mal vielleicht übersetzt für die
bürgerinnen und bürger die uns hier zu
hören kann ich doch einfach mal
feststellen und ich bin ein großer
anhänger des ins feld dass wir einen
großen menschheits fortschritt aber das
ist meine persönliche meinung darüber
kann man streiten aber ich kann doch mal
vorstellen ganz einfach dass ein
eingriff am körper eines bürgers doch
für tendenziell ein weiterer gegner
beschluss des bundestages ist als wenn
es das nicht gibt das ist doch wohl ganz
offensichtlich und deswegen fast
zusammen deswegen lasse ich zusammen nur
weil sie keine mehrheit als ampel haben
ist meine fraktion nicht bereit auf
logik und ein parlamentarisches sauberes
verfahren zu verzichten vielen dank
so kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben
jetzt die geschäftsordnungsdebatte zur
abstimmungs reihenfolge geführt jetzt
müssen wir sie festlegen das soll im
wege des stimmzettel verfahrens mit
stimme ausweis erfolgen auf dem
stimmzettel können sie sich für eine der
beiden abstimmungs reihenfolgen
entscheiden oder sich gegenüber beiden
varianten enthalten angenommen ist der
vorschlag der die meisten stimmen auf
sich vereint ich sehe dass sie mit
diesem verfahren einverstanden sind das
ist so beschlossen damit kommen wir zur
abstimmung über die reihenfolge der
namentlichen abstimmung die
schriftführerin und schriftführer sind
bereits einigen plätzen an den ausgabe
tischen an den uhren an den ausgabe
tischen in der west lobby erhalten sie
nach vorzeigen ihre stimmkarte ihre
stimme ausweises in der farbe rosa einen
rosafarbenen stimmt so die abgeordneten
erheben sich und es beginnt nun die
abstimmung aber noch nicht über die vier
vorschläge sondern erst einmal über die
abstimmungs reihenfolge ich glaube es
ist deutlich geworden wie hart
gestritten wurde debattiert wurde weil
eben klar ist jede gruppe hat da auch
gewisse hoffnungen was diese reihenfolge
angeht eine ganz ganz kritische sache
während also abgestimmt wird wir kommen
dann gleich wieder zurück in den
bundestag wollen wir einfach nach dieser
langen langen debatte also es sind bald
drei stunden die wir jetzt schon
zugehört haben wo viele argumente
ausgetauscht worden sind das ganze auch
noch mal ein bisschen einordnen und
diskutieren mit jemanden der an
vorderster front ist nämlich mit
professor ulf dittmer chef virologie an
der uniklinik essen der uns jetzt
zugeschaltet ist herr professor dietmar
erst einmal ganz liebe grüße und vielen
dank dass sie mit dabei sind ja guten
tag sagen hätten sie haben jetzt
sicherlich nicht die ganzen drei stunden
sich mit angehört und alle argumente
aber es liegen ja nun vier vorträge
anträge auf dem tisch zwei lehnen eine
impfpflicht ab das ist die gruppe um fdp
politiker kubicki das ist die afb die
immer schon eine impfpflicht abgelehnt
hat auch für personal kliniken auch in
pflegeeinrichtungen so und dann sind da
diese zwei vorschläge von der cdu/csu im
grunde genommen eine stufenweise eine
stufenweise vorgehensweise aber nicht
direkt eine impfpflicht sondern erst
einmal der aufbau eines registers und
wärme es besprochen von der
ampelkoalition dieser kompromiss aus dem
forderung aus der forderung impfpflicht
ab 18 aus der forderung im pflicht ab 50
ist jetzt ein kompromiss geworden
impfpflicht ab 60 ordnen sie das ganz
einfach mal ein wofür wären sie
ja kompromiss hat sich ja immer so als
wenn man jetzt nicht mehr wie optimale
lösung vorschlagen würde aber
tatsächlich ist es so wenn man das nach
gesundheitsaspekten einordnet und sich
fragt wer ist bei der omicron variante
gesundheitlich wirklich noch gefährdet
dann sehen wir aus großen datensätzen
aus den usa ist sind die über
60-jährigen ungeimpften wie er schwer
erkrankt sind und von denen viele
gestorben sind in den usa insofern ist
dieser sogenannte
kompromissvorschlag eigentlich
medizinisch der sinnvollste
jetzt ist damit verbunden auch eine
beratungspflicht für die 18 jährigen bis
60 jährigen was halten sie denn davon
reicht das aus sagen sie klar es wäre
schön die imf lücke zu schließen und
auch noch da impfwillige zu überzeugen
oder würden sie sagen es wäre vielleicht
auch besser wenn sozusagen mehr druck
auf die jüngeren noch ausgeübt wird die
nicht geimpft sind
ja ich glaube dass wir den eigentlich
nicht brauchen weil was wir jetzt
gesehen haben mit der nikon variante ist
dass wir in vielen fällen eine infektion
eben mit der impfung nicht verhindern
können das war bei anderen varianten
vorher anders aber das medizinische
risiko bei jüngeren menschen als sei
denn sie haben eine schwere
vorerkrankung des immunsystems zb das
sind noch mal andere fälle das
medizinische risiko ist aber doch
deutlich jünger geworden als wir das
vorher bei den varianten hatten deswegen
müssen wir uns eigentlich bei der
diskussion auf die älteren menschen
konzentrieren und fokussieren
sicherlich ist es sinnvoll auch mit
jüngeren menschen noch mal über das
thema impfung zu sprechen ich finde die
beratung nicht schlecht aber mehr druck
brauchen wir an dieser stelle nicht
unbedingt ok herr professor sie haben so
ein bisschen eine sache angeschnitten
schon der blick in die zukunft eben auch
es ist in der debatte ja auch klar
geworden es geht jetzt gar nicht so sehr
um das jetzt sondern um eine vorsorge
eine vorbereitung da sagen ja die
befürworter dieses ampelkoalition
vorschlags des kompromissvorschlags dass
man gewappnet ist gerüstet ist für den
herbst wenn wahrscheinlich wieder zahlen
ansteigen und in der debatte ist auch
sehr deutlich geworden was ist denn wenn
welche variante vielleicht wieder
auftaucht fand das also sehr interessant
wolfgang kubicki der ja komplett eine
impfpflicht ablehnen sagt jetzt haben
wir auch mikron ist viel milder als
delta da wird nichts schlimmes mehr
kommen und aus dem anderen lager wurde
ihm entgegengehalten moment wo haben sie
denn die kristallkugel herz virologen
etc haben eigentlich keine variante ob
omikron delta wie auch immer präzise
vorhersagen können woher lieber herr
kubicki wollen sie also wissen das nicht
im herbst eine sehr gefährliche völlig
neue variante kommt deshalb jetzt frage
an sie als expertin ist herr kubicki hat
er recht dass man sagt jetzt braucht man
auch gar nicht mehr so viel maßnahmen
sich zurecht legen es wird nichts
schlimmes mehr kommen oder kann es
tatsächlich sein dass vielleicht im
winter im herbst eine ganz andere neue
unentdeckte variante kommt die
tatsächlich dann ziemlich gefährlich
sein kann
ja also erstmal ist diese einschätzung
es wird nichts schlimmes mehr kommen
schon bei unicom falsches sind in den
usa holz da soviel ungeimpfte ältere gab
mehr menschen gestorben als an dem
welthandels was sehr gefährlich war also
die grundannahme ist da erst mal schon
mal falsch ich glaube nicht tatsächlich
dass wir eine deutlich tödlichere
variante als omikron im winter erleben
werden evolutionär hat sich das für sehr
unwahrscheinlich das ist eigentlich
nicht der weg der infektion der
evolution da geht es immer darum mehr zu
infizieren aber nicht mehr krank zu
machen
aber auch bei solchen werden wie auch
mikron haben müssten ältere geschützt
seien durch die impfung weil das
gesundheitsmesse ich noch sehr
gefährlich ist das virus und dann also
sie machen glasklar also sie würden den
ampel
koalitionskompromiss durchaus
befürworten weil sie eben sagen es sind
die älteren die durch eine impfpflicht
geschützt werden müssten wenn wir doch
jetzt mal den vorschlag der union oder
der von der union eingebracht worden ist
uns anschauen die gehen eben hin und
sagen erst einmal sortieren einen
überblick bekommen ein impf register
aufbauen und dann kann man ja später
immer noch sozusagen wenn die impflücken
deutlich zu groß ist dann sozusagen
flexibel entscheiden und dann
entsprechend reagieren also ein
gestuftes verfahren die gegner haben
gesagt na ja man kann die feuerwehrwache
doch nicht erst aufbauen wenn es brennt
man muss die feuerwehrwache vorher
aufbauen wie sehen sie das
ja wir haben ja in dieser partie in den
letzten zwei jahren gesehen dass wir mit
einigen politischen entscheidungen dann
doch zu spät dran waren und die
befürchtung ist natürlich groß dass wenn
man jetzt nicht eine entscheidung herbei
führt dass das eben wieder so sein
könnte auch mit der impfung von älteren
im nächsten herbst oder winter und ich
möchte daran erinnern dass wir die del
tabelle schon sehr extrem im letzten
august hatten also wir brauchen nicht
nur auf oktober zu gucken sondern das
ging massiv im august los ich halte
allerdings die idee ein im register
aufzubauen für sehr sinnvoll und wichtig
die skandinavischen länder die das alle
haben haben viel bessere zahlen zu
impfungen als wir auch viel bessere
zahlen zu nebenwirkungen von impfungen
als wir das es eigentlich längst
überfällig in deutschland
wie schätzen sie denn generell die
situation hier ein
je nachdem welche fraktion welche rät da
jetzt gesprochen hat werden zahlen ja
auch unterschiedlich interpretiert also
es ist so dass das lka heute 201
1729 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
gemeldet hat das sind 73 1000 fälle
weniger als vor einer woche mit anderen
worten diese infektionszahlen sinken die
instituts entsprechend auch aber
328 tote in zusammenhang mit 19
innerhalb von 24 stunden das ist ja auch
nicht gerade wenig jetzt wurde das
wieder unterschiedlich interpretiert die
gegner einer endlich sagen wir haben
sowieso sinkende zahlen also soll man
doch jetzt auch die leute selbst
entscheiden lassen und keine weiteren
maßnahmen treffen herr lauterbach der
gesundheitsminister hat auch noch mal
dran erinnert zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
über 300 tote jeden tag ist ein bisschen
viel und man muss es drücken wie sehen
sie jetzt eigentlich die die derzeitige
entwicklung wo wir jetzt stehen
ja wir stehen da wo andere länder schon
vor uns gestanden haben und darum
gekommen die zahlen sinken jetzt zum
glück wir haben zwei verschiedene tricks
und deutschland gehabt erst die unter
variante ba1 und dann ba2 hinterher und
dann tritt so ein sättigungseffekt a 1
bei diesen hohen infektionszahlen und
die zahlen gehen erstmal nach unten
wir sehen jetzt aber an ländern die das
schon vorher durch gemacht haben dass
die zahlen dann auf einem relativ hohen
niveau verharren und auch durchaus
wieder steigen können wie jetzt in
england
das heißt wir werden weiterhin mit
diesem virus leben müssen wir können
jetzt nicht ableiten dass alles vorbei
ist nur weil die zahlen jetzt sinken wir
müssen uns mit diesem thema weiter
beschäftigen
jetzt werde ich eine sache auch eine
argumentation mit ihnen besprechen von
afg rednern kam immer wieder das
argument ich bin ja zweimal geimpft aber
ich habe mich trotzdem infiziert also
die ganze impfung das nützt ja alles
nichts und wenn sie eine impfpflicht
einführen wollen dann wollen sie die
menschen zu etwas zwingen war nichts
nützt da gab es heftige gegenrede
lauterbach und andere mehr deutlich
gemacht eben dass das impfen ja nicht
vor der infektion schützen soll sondern
eben vor dem schweren verlauf können sie
das einfach noch mal diese argumente die
einfach heute ja im bundestag
ausgesprochen worden sind noch einfach
mal einen aus der sicht des virologen
ja das ist eben medizinisch eine
komplette fehleinschätzung kamen wir
wissen aus allen studien aus allen
ländern dass zumindest die rna
impfstoffe hervorragend gegen erkrankung
nach infektion von mit lars koch zwei
schützen haben zu einem sehr sehr hohen
prozentsatz
und es ist eben so dass dafür die
impfstoffe entwickelt worden sind
zwischendurch bei einigen varianten
hatten wir die komfortable situation
dass die impfung auch sehr gut gegen
infektionen geschützt hat dass es mit
orten konnte teilweise verloren gegangen
oder sogar zu einem großen teil aber der
schutz vor erkrankung ist weiterhin
hervorragend und diese zahlen aus den
usa die ich eben schon genannt hat dort
sind in der mikrowelle die menschen über
60 dem nicht geimpft waren gestorben und
auf der intensivstation gelandet 20 fach
erhöht im gegensatz zu über 60 jährigen
die enten die geimpft waren also das
risiko und dieser schutz vor
erkrankungen
der ist eindeutig jetzt noch mal ein
anderes argumente also eine klare
aussprache für das impfen eben also für
eine impfpflicht was er aber auch immer
wieder diskutiert worden ist und gerade
eben vertreter der fdp haben ja auch
deutlich gemacht dass sie eben hingehen
und sagen
das impfen ist ja eine hoch persönliche
sache und die entscheidende formulierung
ist sozusagen dient das impfen dem
selbstschutz dann soll man nicht den
menschen zu seinem eigenen glück wurde
oft gesagt zwingen man darf nicht jemand
zu seinem selbstschutz zwingend es ist
was anderes wenn es um den schutz der
gesamten bevölkerung geht und das
argument war immer hier das impfen das
ist ja eine frage des schutzes also muss
man das als freiwillige entscheidung den
menschen überlassen wie sehen sie das
denn jetzt als virologe schütze ich mich
mit dem impfen nur selbst oder ist wenn
eine impfpflicht eingeführt ab 60 und
der unwillige sich impft ist dann damit
doch der effekt eben auch dafür andere
ja es ist tatsächlich so dass bei
umgekommen der selbstschutz bei der
impfung absolut im vordergrund steht das
ist eben anders als bei anderen
varianten vorher da hatten wir auch
einen hervorragenden fremdschutz der es
mit omikron leider zum großteil verloren
gegangen und es geht hier jetzt vor
allen dingen um den selbstschutz muss
man ganz klar sagen
und es ist aber auch natürlich ein
schutz des gesundheitssystems weil diese
patienten zahlen die zum beispiel in den
usa ende angekommen weil er da gewesen
sind die haben dazu geführt dass andere
medizinische behandlung in den
krankenhäusern faktisch kaum noch
durchgeführt werden konnten also wir
beschäftigen uns sonst weiterhin sehr
sehr viel in diesem gesundheitssystem in
unserem gesundheitssystem mit dem kobold
19 patienten und leider zu wenig mit
anderen erkrankungen an das haben wir
jetzt schon zwei jahre lang zu gemacht
und zusammen wir schieben einen berg
meiner ansicht nach von anderen
erkrankungen wie auch im krankenhaus
behandelt werden müssen vor uns her ohne
dass wir jetzt eine völlige überlastung
situationen gekommen werden aber wir
haben hier eine man kann das ja ganz
leicht sehen an allen anderen
krankenhausbehandlungen die sind in den
letzten zwei jahren deutlich
zurückgegangen
also mit anderen worten wir haben zwar
viele zahlen auch wie gesagt frisch die
vom rk ii 328 tote innerhalb von 24
stunden aber wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe was ja gar nicht beziffert
werden kann sind zum beispiel dann die
langzeitfolgen bzw vielleicht auch toten
die wegen einer verschobenen
krebsoperation ja gar nicht in so eine
statistik kommen aber letzten endes auf
vielleicht nicht impfungen damit schwere
fälle krankenhaus einen lieferungen
zurückzuführen sind richtig
genau da wissen wir eigentlich ziemlich
wählen ich drüber und nahmen keine
besonders guten zahlen natürlich
behandeln wir die schwerkranken ge
schwerst erkrankten in den letzten zwei
jahren auch trotz kurve 19 aber andere
eingriffe sind immer wieder verschoben
worden und auch personen die eine
schwere beschädigung haben und quasi
nicht mehr laufen konnten können leiden
sehr stark darunter wenn sie nicht
operiert werden können und solche
eingriffe schieben würde jetzt schon
länger von ca
er präsentiert mal dann erstmal vielen
vielen dank wir haben damit dann doch
mit ihrer virologischen expertise einige
argumente die ausgetauscht worden sind
auch einige behauptungen sage ich jetzt
einfach mal die im parlament in drei
stunden gilt werte gefallen sind die wir
gehört haben doch eingeordnet auf den
wahrheitsgehalt überprüft und das ganze
ein bisschen geklärt erstmal vielen
vielen dank jetzt wollen wir ins
parlament bringen tschüss und viele
grüße nochmal nach essen wir wollen
nämlich jetzt zurück ins parlament
bringen denn andrea maurer hat dort den
auch gescholtenen aber auch aus
teilenden thorsten frei den
parlamentarischen geschäftsführer der
union und wir sind gespannt was er denn
jetzt zu der debatte sagt und während
immer noch ausgezählt wird wie denn
jetzt der ganze ablauf heute ist
ja genau also bei mir ist's her frei der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer
hallo herr frei es ist ja tatsächlich
eine sehr hitzige debatte gewesen viele
vorwürfe sind durch den raum geflogen
auch der vorwurf an die union sozusagen
aus parteitaktik zu blockieren wie haben
sie die debatte erlebt ja das war eine
unangemessene schärfe das würde ich
wirklich sagen denn ich glaube muss
zugute halten dass alle versuchen die
aus ihrer sicht beste lösung zu
erreichen wir blockieren gar nichts wir
haben einen eigenen klugen abgewogenen
vorschlag gemacht den stellen wir zur
abstimmung und dafür werben wir um
zustimmung und es ist ja bezeichnend
dass gerade die redner der
ampelkoalition uns immer wieder mit
diesen vorwürfen konfrontiert haben im
grunde genommen geht er ja an die
eigenen reihen es ist ja nur deshalb so
weil sie keine mehrheit in der eigenen
koalition habe und deswegen ist es
einfach unredlich uns die ehrlichkeit in
der debatte hier abzusprechen ehrmann
klugen vorschlag gemacht der die zeit
jetzt nutzt um vorbereitet zu sein für
den herbst und den winter ohne in einer
situation wo die voraussetzungen nicht
gegeben sind bereits eine impfpflicht zu
beschließen insofern haben wir
eigentlich den klassischen
kompromissvorschlag gemacht es hat ja
gestern auch ein brief die runde gemacht
den sie geschrieben haben an die
abgeordneten der union und darin
aufgefordert haben sozusagen geschlossen
für den vorschlag der union zustimmen
sich auch noch nicht mehr zu enthalten
auch auf keinen fall für den
gesetzentwurf sozusagen den die ampel
favorisiert zustimmen es stellt sich
natürlich die frage wieviel
gewissensfrage oder wie viele freie
entscheidung der abgeordneten da dann
möglich ist selbstverständlich haben die
abgeordneten eine freie entscheidung
es ist so dass wir unseren antrag der
fraktion liga einstand nicht
abgeschlossen haben nicht anrufen beim
schreiben die kollegen noch einmal
hingewiesen
deswegen ist es im grunde genommen
selbstredend dass wenn man in der
fraktion dafür stimmt dass man das im
parlament dann auch macht die frage ob
etwas eine gewissensentscheidung ist
entscheidet nicht der bundeskanzler
übrigens auch nicht
fraktionsvorsitzender
sondern das entscheidet jeder
abgeordnete für sich und wenn auch bei
uns abgeordnete sagen ich kann nach
meinem gewissen nicht so abstimmen wie
es die mehrheit der fraktion wünscht
dann akzeptieren wird es das ist eine
selbstverständlichkeit
übrigens nicht nur bei dieser sondern
auch bei vielen oder allen anderen
entscheidungen ist es so aber es gibt
keine vorgabe hier sozusagen so zu
entscheiden wie man das möchte jeder
entscheidet das für sich selbst und
ansonsten das hat gute tradition
beschließen wir in der fraktion wie wir
uns gemeinsam aufstellen und treten dann
auch gemeinsam im parlament an ein
vorwurf der sie auch erreicht hat ist
sie seien eben nicht für gespräche
erreichbar gewesen also man hätte
versucht sie telefonisch anzurufen
was sagen sie dazu das kann man klar
widerlegen wir hatten letzte woche ja
auch zahlreiche gespräche
unterschiedlicher art tatsächlich ist es
so dass es diese gespräche ab montag
sozusagen nicht mehr gegeben hat da
haben wir dann zunächst einen vorschlag
einer im 50 am dienstagabend dann einen
vorschlag einer impfpflicht ab 60 wenige
stunden vor der abschließenden
entscheidung des gesundheitsausschusses
erlebt da waren wir jeweils nicht mit
einbezogen auch nicht angefragt oder
dergleichen ich lass das mal im raum
stehen man muss mit uns nicht sprechen
aber man sollte uns nicht vorwerfen wir
wären nicht ansprechbar wenn man uns
überhaupt nicht anspricht er frei am
ende dieses tages könnte er tatsächlich
die tatsache stehen dass deutschland
keine impfpflicht bekommen wird noch
nicht mal mehr einen mechanismus der
dann zieht falls es irgendwie noch mal
eine verschärfte lage gibt also es
könnte ja durchaus das ergebnis sein
wenn der gesetzentwurf nicht durchkommt
und auch kein anderer antrag eine
mehrheit kriegt es das dann wert also
zunächst einmal ist es keine wert
entscheidung es gibt in europa zwei
länder die eine impfpflicht haben
griechenland und italien
und es gibt ein dutzend länder in der
welt die eine impfpflicht haben die
allermeisten haben es nicht aber darüber
hinaus ist es natürlich so dass wir ab
heute nachmittag gerne auch für weitere
gespräche zur verfügung stehen also wir
haben uns dem in der vergangenheit nicht
verschlossen wir tun das auch zukünftig
nicht wir haben auch die abstimmung
heute nicht erzwungen es war der wunsch
der ampel das so zu machen wir hätten
gerne auch noch weiter sprechen können
insofern akzeptieren wir das dass die
ampel das nun zum abschluss hut bringen
wollen aber wir sind da nicht dafür
verantwortlich wenn die ampel ihre ziele
nicht erreichen sollten es entsteht
natürlich dann in der bevölkerung der
eindruck man hat jetzt vier monate
geredet es war auch irgendwie eine
debatte die sehr zerfasert ist jetzt
noch mal weiter zu reden was wohin soll
das dann führen also es war eine
zerfaserte langwierige debatte weil sich
die koalition in ampel anträge
geflüchtet hat das hat das ganze
verfahren stark verkompliziert wenn der
bundeskanzler sagt er hat dort ein thema
das ist für ihn die lösung aus der
pandemie dann muss er mit seiner
koalition dafür auch eine mehrheit
zustande bringen er kann jederzeit auch
mit uns als oppositionsfraktion sprechen
und nach einer gemeinsamen lösung suchen
da haben wir überhaupt kein problem
damit aber das sozusagen aus der hand zu
geben zu sagen ich warte mal ab was im
parlament passiert das haben wir ja
jetzt gesehen wir haben eine sehr harte
debatte und diskussion und dafür
übernehmen wir nun wirklich nicht die
verantwortung das ist die verantwortung
der regierungskoalition wie ist ihre
prognose wird das heute ausgehen ich
halte es ehrlich gesagt für offen wir
haben sehr viele kolleginnen und
kollegen die
krankheits oder quarantäne bedingt heute
nicht dabei sein können deswegen kanzlei
kann es durchaus zu einer verschiebung
in den abstimmungsergebnissen kommen ich
halte es für offen wir werden sehen was
der tag bringt so oder so ist es kein
beinbruch das ist glaube ich die
entscheidende botschaft und wie auch
immer werden wir unsere arbeit
anschließend fortsetzen und zwar so dass
es bestmöglich für unser land und seine
menschen ist vielen dank herr frey ich
glaube sie müssen jetzt noch mal weiter
zu der nächsten abstimmung oder zu den
abstimmungen dankeschön auf jeden fall
schon mal an dieser stelle danke ja also
kassen du hast das gehört es gibt hier
tatsächlich viele fragezeichen wie diese
debatte oder überhaupt diese abstimmung
heute hier ausgehen werden es ist eine
hitzige debatte eine inhaltliche debatte
gewesen die wir hier heute erlebt haben
es ist tatsächlich an vielen stellen der
vorwurf hervorgebracht worden dass es um
parteitaktik geht nicht mehr um die
sache und zwar aus allen richtungen ist
dieser vorwurf vorgebracht worden
fraktionsübergreifend ja und das ist
sozusagen heute der tag im parlament der
in seinem ausgang offen ist
ja vielen vielen dank andrea und wir
wollen weiter beobachten wir sehen mit
einem rechten auge das floß die
stellvertretende
bundestagspräsidentin dass sie nämlich
sehen wir es gemeinsam zum mikrofon
greift und einen zettel gereicht
bekommen hat die sitzung wird von ihr
gerade wieder eröffnet wir können ja mal
ganz kurz reinhören ob sie das ergebnis
über die erste abstimmung nämlich über
die abstimmungs reihenfolge schon hat
und das ist dann hofballett hörmann
folge verließen
mitgliederzahl im deutschen bundestag
736 abgegebene stimmkarten
686 es gab keine ungültige stimmen karte
von den ab gebenden stimmen entfielen
auf reihenfolge 1
345 stimmen und auf reihenfolge 2
339 stimmen
enthaltungen
enthaltungen 2
entsprechend des ausgezählten
ergebnisses der abstimmung werden wir in
folgender reihenfolge
abstimmen reihenfolge 1 das bedeutet
gesetzentwurf behrens janitschek und
andere antrag cdu csu antrag kubicki und
andere antrag afd
bevor wir zu den abstimmungen kommen
bitte ich um ihre aufmerksamkeit für
einige hinweise zum abstimmungsverfahren
der ausschuss für gesundheit hat in
seiner beschlussempfehlung auf
drucksache 13 53 unter buchstaben b c
und d empfohlen über die anträge auf den
drucksachen
978 und 516 im plenum einen beschluss
herbeizuführen
selbst aber keine inhaltliche empfehlung
abgegeben unter buchstabe a seiner
beschlussempfehlung hat der ausschuss
die gesetzentwürfe der gruppen behrens
und janácek auf drucksachen
899 und
954 zusammengeführt und in einer
ausschuss fassung vorgelegt über die
vorlagen stimmen wir nun in der
festgelegten reihenfolge die ich eben
verlesen habe ab wird eine vorlage
angenommen
entfällt die abstimmung über die
weiteren vorlagen wir kommen also jetzt
zur ersten namentlichen abstimmung
[Applaus]
das schön dass sie sich darüber freuen
also wir stimmen jetzt ab
über den gesetzentwurf behrens
janitschek und andere der gesetz zur
pandemie versorgung vorsorge durch
aufklärung verpflichtende impfberatung
hier nicht so richtig 345
sehen wir auch andrea wieder jetzt
wissen wir zumindest wie das spannende
spiel die spannende abstimmung heute
weiter geht nämlich es wird zuerst über
den vorschlag über den gesetzentwurf der
ampel koalition abgestimmt dann über den
antrag von cdu/csu dann über den
vorschlag nämlich keinerlei impfpflicht
von fdp-politiker kubicki und co und
dann erst über die afd eigentlich andrea
doch ein ja sieg der union eine
niederlage für die ampel die ja versucht
hat diese abstimmungs reihenfolge anders
zu gestalten
tatsächlich ist es so dass es der ampel
nicht gelungen ist eine mehrheit zu
kriegen für die reihenfolge die sie
favorisiert hat bei mir ist jetzt der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer der
linken jan korte herr korte sie haben
das ja jetzt die letzten tage hautnah
miterlebt wie auch darum gerungen wurde
mehrheiten zu organisieren können sie
mal sagen was das jetzt bedeutet dass es
zu dieser reihenfolge kommt ja zunächst
einmal ist das natürlich eine amtliche
klatsche für die ampelkoalition denn wir
sind heute in der situation dass die
ampel versucht hat über eine frage der
reihenfolge
ihre nicht vorhandene mehrheit irgendwie
doch noch zustande zu bekommen und da
sage ich es gibt ja ein klares verfahren
nämlich übersetzt für die menschen man
entscheidet immer zuerst den
weitestgehenden antrag und das ist ja
wenn wir über impfpflicht reden
natürlich die entscheidung also ob ich
nun beim bürger die nadel ansätze wenn
man so will oder ob das nicht geschieht
das ist ja wohl deutlich weitgehender
und da haben sie versucht das anders
herum zu machen und das ist jetzt mit
mehrheit nicht gelungen was ich für das
verfahren außerordentlich sinnvoll finde
was aber natürlich noch nichts darüber
sagt die sich jetzt gleich abgeordneten
entscheiden werden wie sehr würde da
auch um die linke geworben ja also es
wurde schon sehr darum geworben und das
ist natürlich auch immer ein hinweis
dafür dass es dieser ampel koalition
keine mehrheit gibt deswegen haben wir
auch dies tobago hier mit gruppen
anträgen anträgen gesetzt werden dürfen
und alles denn es ist eigentlich aufgabe
der bundesregierung hier was vorzulegen
und deswegen kann nicht nur konstatieren
die korona chaos politik die jetzt seit
zweieinhalb jahren die leute wirklich
auf die palme bringt die wird munter
fortgesetzte jetzt eben mit karl
lauterbach an der spitze es könnte jetzt
tatsächlich sein dass wenn es keine
mehrheit für den gesetzentwurf den die
ampel favorisiert gibt das dann am ende
hier wir aus diesem parlament rausgehen
und es gibt keine impfpflicht und es
gibt auch keinen mechanismus der eine
impfpflicht
implementieren würde sollte sich die
lage verschärfen
was würden sie zu einem ergebnis dann
sagt ja das ist dann natürlich wirklich
ein debakel für die diese politik zu
verantworten haben dann müssen wir
gucken was machen wir denn ich sage das
ganz klar ich bin ein großer anhänger
der impfpflicht bin natürlich auch
selber geimpft und gepustet das ist ein
wesentlicher baustein nur er hilft
natürlich nicht insgesamt denn die leute
packen sich an die birne hier wird die
masken pflicht aufgehoben und
gleichzeitig sollen wir eine impfpflicht
einführen da blickt ja kein mensch durch
dann kann es nur darum gehen mit einer
wirklich zugespitzten aufsuchenden
impfkampagne möglichst hohe impfquoten
zu erreichen denn davon bin ich auch
überzeugt dass das natürlich ein ganz
wichtiger weg ist aber eben nur ein
stein auf dem weg zur beendigung der
pandemie die linke wird ja jetzt
umworben aber sie ist selber auch nicht
ganz eindeutig also wir haben eben sahra
wagenknecht gesehen die für die gruppe
kubicki hier am rednerpult gestanden ist
auch herr gysi hat sich dieser gruppe
angeschlossen wie ist denn das
meinungsbild in ihrer frage das ist halt
durchschnittlich sowie in der fraktion
auch wir haben strikte befürworter einer
impfpflicht wir haben eine größere
gruppe die ist er grundsätzlich dagegen
dort ist ein argument was auch nicht
ganz von der hand zu weisen ist das wenn
ich ein gesetz beschließe von dem ich
weiß dass es nicht durchsetzen kann ist
es natürlich fragt würde ich so ein
gesetz zu beschließen
also wir haben dort das ganze spektrum
wie alle anderen fraktionen auch und das
ist ja auch keine so einfache frage und
was ist ihre prognose wie geht es weiter
ich glaube wir müssen ab morgen alles
daran tun eine große impfkampagne zu
machen dass wir mehr freiwillige impfung
bekommen wer meine prognose stand jetzt
also herr korte glaubt nicht an eine
mehrheit heute für diesen gesetzentwurf
vielen dank schon mal an dieser stelle
herr korte sie müssen jetzt glaube ich
auch zur abstimmung ja danke schön ja
also es ist tatsächlich so dass schon in
der abstimmung über die reihenfolge der
abstimmung die ampel es nicht geschafft
hat eine mehrheit für den vorschlag zu
organisieren den sie favorisiert hat
also sie hätte es gerne gehabt dass der
gesetzentwurf den eben karl lauterbach
und der kanzler befürworten am ende
abgestimmt wird damit der so eine art
auffangbecken ist für für für menschen
die eben nicht wollen dass es heute
keine entscheidung gibt so wird es jetzt
nicht kommen es wird über diesen antrag
nun oder über diesen gesetzentwurf
zuerst abgestimmt und das ist
tatsächlich hier weiterhin spannend und
im ausgang völlig offen
andrea erstmal vielen dank für die
informationen das zeigt dass sich
sozusagen recht hatte als ich um 9 uhr
es ist schon lange her fast fünf stunden
vier stunden dass man das ist ein
spannender tag wird vielleicht ordnen
wir das gemeinsam noch mal ein hat ich
habe ja irgendwo den eindruck oder wir
kriegen doch alle gemeinsam diesen
eindruck dass diese ampel koalition
wirklich ringt und ringt und ringt und
echt große schwierigkeiten hat bei
diesem thema etwa sozusagen auf die
schiene zu setzen
der kanzler hat am anfang vor vier
monaten als das thema impfpflicht bei
der delta variante aufkommt aufkam man
muss ja noch mal da in erinnerung
gerufen dass er alle parteien ganz am
anfang gesagt haben eine impfpflicht
kommt niemals dann kam aber delta dann
kamen
schwere fälle auch die menschen in
umfragen haben gesagt wir wollen eine
impfpflicht und dann wurde dieses thema
auf den schild gehoben und der kanzler
hat gesagt ja okay eine impfpflicht soll
kommen und zwar ab 18 dann gab es einige
die haben gesagt naja aber eine
impfpflicht ab 50 das wäre uns lieber ab
18 ist vielleicht zu viel und jetzt
müssen wir doch mal einfach mal schauen
weil es offenbar gar keine mehrheit für
einen dieser vorschläge gab hat man sich
du musst das noch mal erklären andrea in
letzter minute zusammengerauft diese
gruppe lauterbach und auch der kanzler
hatte ja gesagt ab 18 und dann um damen
von den grünen herum ab 50 die
impfpflicht und der kompromiss ist also
jetzt ab 60 was ist denn überhaupt
erstmal da vorher gelaufen
ja es war ja tatsächlich so wie du es
sagst es gab eine gruppe ich nenne sie
jetzt mal stolz lauterbach weil es
einfach der vorschlag war den die beiden
favorisiert haben die haben eine
impfpflicht ab 18 befürwortet die jetzt
im herbst eben kommen soll da gab es
dann tatsächlich probleme mehr eine
mehrheit dafür zu finden diese gruppe
hat sich zusammengetan mit der gruppe um
den fdp-abgeordneten andrew ullmann der
war für eine impfpflicht ab 50 aber
vorangehen der beratungsangebote und
sozusagen eine möglichkeit diese
impfpflicht dann auch erst mal scharf zu
stellen wenn es die lage erfordert diese
beiden gruppen haben sich
zusammengefunden zu einem kompromiss der
kompromiss war dann im pflicht ab 60 mit
der möglichkeit im juni noch einmal zu
entscheiden entsprechend der impfquote
ob es diese impfpflicht ab 60 ab dem
ersten oktober dann tatsächlich braucht
und wenn sie denn kommt ob es das sie
dann möglicherweise auch im herbst noch
mal hätte scharf gestellt werden können
auf impfpflicht ab 18 das war der
kompromiss mit diesem kompromiss wollte
man die hand reichen sowohl an die
abgeordneten die sich andrew ullmann
angeschlossen haben als auch man wollte
die hand reichen an die union denn es
gab es gibt tatsächlich in diesen
vorschlag auch der die idee eines images
das impfpflicht auf 60 ist auch in den
unions-vorschlag vorhanden aber die
union hat eben diese hand nicht
angenommen hat sich kompromisslos
gezeigt er hat gesagt wir haben selber
einen antrag vorgelegt an den glauben
wir felsenfest das ist der kompromiss
dem könnt ihr euch anschließen und
fallen sind wir nicht
mehrheitsbeschaffer für eine ampel die
es nicht schafft ihre eigenen reihen zu
schließen das ist die position der union
dann gibt es eben noch den antrag der
afd gegen eine impfpflicht und auch
gegen die einrichtungs bezogen die
impfpflicht dass die noch mal
abgeschafft wird und es gibt einen
antrag rund um den fdp abgeordneten
wolfgang kubicki das war tatsächlich
auch der erste antrag der hier auf dem
tisch lag der sieht der ist eben auch
gegen eine impfpflicht aber dafür dass
geworben wird für für das impfen das ist
ein antrag der ehrlich gesagt auch
ziemlich viel zustimmung
fraktionsübergreifend gefunden hat also
wir haben es eben gehört sahra
wagenknecht hat sich dem angeschlossen
und es gibt eben viele andere politiker
auch aus anderen fraktionen die für
diesen antrag sind das ist die
gemengelage was wir hier vor allem aus
der fdp also aus der ampel partei fdp
hören ist das auch an prominenter stelle
also der geschäftsführer der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer der
fraktionschef der generalsekretär die
alle wollen auf keinen fall für den
gesetzentwurf stimmen für den scholz und
lauterbach sind das heißt im grunde
genommen ist da die ampel auseinander
dividiert und choice der ja diese
abstimmung freigegeben hat also zu einer
freien gewissensentscheidung erklärt hat
der wollte ja damals eben nicht die fdp
verärgern und dachte er könnte sozusagen
bei der union und anderen parteien eine
mehrheit für die impfpflicht finden das
ist die gemengelage es ist ein chaos ist
es inzwischen partei politisches
geschachere um diese im pflicht der
ampel wir haben es gesehen ist jetzt
schon in der ersten abstimmung zur
reihenfolge über die abstimmung
gescheitert und es ist eben fraglich wie
es jetzt weitergeht hinter mir wird
jetzt das erste mal abgestimmt und es
wird sich hier auf jeden fall
noch eine weile hinziehen wir hören
jetzt gleich dann das ergebnis wie viele
abgeordnete sich eben hinter den antrag
hinter dem gesetzentwurf stellen für den
karl lauterbach und olaf scholz sind das
wird ein erstes sehr maßgeblicher
stimmungsbild sein tja andere ja erstmal
vielen vielen dank dass du das chaos ein
bisschen sortiert hass und ja auch
nochmal letzten endes die vier anträge
die vier vorschläge die auf dem tisch
sind stehen zur abstimmung noch einmal
erläutert hass und über eben diese vier
vorschläge den gesetzentwurf und auch
die anderen drei vorschläge ja da wurde
heute morgen ja nun heftig diskutiert
debattiert alle argumente noch mal
vorgetragen und eben geworben stimmen
sie doch für unseren vorschlag und diese
gut drei stunden debatte die wir live
erlebt haben haben wir noch mal kurz
zusammengefasst daniel ponce noch einmal
über dieses hin und her die debatte
heute morgen
bevor es zur abstimmung kam brachten
abgeordnete aller fraktionen noch einmal
ihre argumente nicht als minister
sondern in seiner funktion als
abgeordneter auf karl lauterbach der
zunächst für eine impfpflicht ab 18
geworben hatte sich zuletzt dann aber
dem kompromiss für jene ab 60 anschluss
werden wir die pflicht ab 60 beginnen
dann verhindern wir 90 prozent der
todesfälle die wir mit einer impfpflicht
verändert hätten 18 davor und danach ein
offener schlagabtausch teils jenseits
von fraktionsgrenzen wenn die data
variante fiel in diesem hause zum